[Musique]
bonsoir et merci de nous rejoindre pour
ce premier débat des législatives sur tv
fil 78 aujourd'hui ce sont les candidats
de la première circonscription des
yvelines qui vont revenir sur quelques
uns des points de leur programme pour
vous aider à trancher lors du premier
tour de scrutin ce sera le dimanche 11
juin vous le voyez ils sont 14 à se
présenter sur cette circonscription avec
cette infographie pour des raisons
techniques nous avons dû structurer
cette émission autour de trois grandes
parties chaque candidat sera en tout cas
chronométrés dans ses réponses pour
assurer au mieux l égalité entre chacun
pour débuter j'accueille françois-xavier
bellamy candidats les républicains
didier baichère face à vous candidat de
la république en marche
thibault marshall à vos côtés à qui est
candidat pour la france insoumise face
avoué thierry perez candidat du front
national et à côté de vous ou charlotte
recette unique candidate ps dans les
yvelines a donc dans cette 1re
circonscription et pour terminer cette
première table de candidats olivier
parent et j'ai un candidat europe
écologie et les verts
bonsoir à tous les six et merci d'avoir
répondu à cette invitation quoi qu'il
arrive il y aura donc un nouveau député
dans cette circonscription le sortant le
maire françois de mazières ayant décidé
en raison de la loi sur le non-cumul des
mandats de privilégier sa commune de
versailles
ce premier tour de table avec une
question est simple et ce sera le mot
d'ordre de la soirée
je vais vous demander d'être con si je
me tourne vers vous pour débuter
pourquoi les électeurs devraient doivent
en faire confiance d'abord merci
beaucoup de cette proposition de débat
que vous nous offrez
je crois que dans cette élection nous
sommes vraiment à un moment décisif pour
la vie de notre de notre pays de notre
société et que dans ce moment décisif il
est nécessaire d'abord d'apporter un
projet clair un projet cohérent
de mon côté je vais essayer de servir un
débat démocratique qui soit d'une grande
qualité et d'une grande exigence de
transparence parce que je crois que la
période des élections présidentielles
nous a tous beaucoup frustré quel que
soit notre sensibilité politique
elle a été marquée par des
rebondissements d'affaires qui
finalement avait très peu à voir avec
les vrais enjeux auxquels notre pays
doit doit faire face est donc la
première chose c'est je crois de pouvoir
faire la proposition d'un projet qui
soit claire et qui soit cohérent qui
soit aussi complet et précis que
possible et c'est ce que je vais essayer
servir y compris dans ceux dans ce débat
et puis la deuxième chose c'est que
cette élection n'est pas seulement une
élection nationale c'est aussi une
élection locale
et si je m'engage dans cette élection
c'est avec le soutien de beaucoup d'élus
de notre équipe municipale du maire de
versailles du maire de montigny qui
m'ont poussé à m'engager parce que
depuis quelques années déjà j'ai
l'occasion d'intervenir sur des fusées
qui touche à l'actualité nationale mais
aussi parce que depuis neuf ans je suis
élu local dans cette ville comme ma
suppléante quête chanabé qui est
adjointe au maire de montigny mais je
crois que ce qui compte pour moi
vraiment le plus c'est que cette
circonscription puisse se sentir
représenté que tous ceux qui y vivent
qui travaillent qui habitent puissent
vraiment être en contact permanent avec
celui qui demain sera à leur député
circonscription qui couvre les communes
de versailles guyancourt et montigny le
bretonneux je n'avais pas précisé en
introduction d'idées bien cher c'est à
vous pourquoi les électeurs doivent
devrait vous faire confiance
voter pour moi c'est voter pour un
projet qui est extrêmement clair puisque
c'est la mise en place du projet qui a
permis à emmanuel macron d'être élu
président de la république
c'est un projet qui a été construit
depuis un an et demi avec les citoyens
puisque on est on est parti d'un travail
où il n'y avait pas d'adhérents en
marche
il ya un an et demi on a construit les
comités locaux et c'est à travers ces
comités locaux que nous avons construit
le président emmanuel macron c'est un
projet qui est clair qu'ils ne subit pas
de modifications entre la présidentielle
les élections législatives aucun
ajustement si les dix mesures
principales qui emmanuel macron a
défendu voilà après je pense que voter
pour moi c'est aussi choisir et ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on a beaucoup entendu
pendant nos échanges avec les
concitoyens sur la circonscription c'est
choisir la vie civile c'est choisir un
candidat qui vient de la vie civile moi
je vis un versailles je travaille à
guyancourt ma suppléante habite à
montigny et travaille également à
guyancourt donc on connaît la
circonscription depuis de très
nombreuses années et on a on a choisi
avec les comités locaux de montigny de
lui en cours et de versailles d'avoir
cinq priorités particulières dans cette
élection à au delà du programme des
manuels macron l'emploi l'éducation la
défense et la sécurité passera beaucoup
d'entreprises de défense sur sur une
circonscription la vie citoyenne qui est
pas juste une lubie qui nous a qui nous
a pris pour les élections c'est parce
qu'on a on a créé ce débat cet échange
avec les citoyens et moi j'ai un
engagement en tant que futurs députés
c'est de continuer à pouvoir évaluer les
politiques de l'état à travers les
comités locaux
et puis le dernier sujet qui est un
sujet
le transverses qui sont les jeux
olympiques que j'essaierai de porter
personnellement j'aimerais c'est à lire
dans ce secteur trois s'arrête là pour
pas empiéter taux sur l'ensemble de
votre temps de parole pour cette
émission je voulais dit nous n'avons
finalement qu'assez peu de temps ce
rendez-vous va durer une heure et demie
il ya de nombreux candidats qui vont
s'exprimer on parlera d'éducation dans
un instant on continue ce premier tour
de table avec vous pour le front
national s'il espérait bien écoutez je
pense que voter pour le front national
c'est voter pour une opposition
aujourd'hui à une forme de un peu de
floutage entre tous ces partis qui
finalement un petit peu explosé en vol
au moment des présidentielles les partis
classiques pour lesquels les français
avaient l'habitude de voter
donc il faut une véritable opposition
une opposition ça veut dire de la
construction ça veut dire ne pas
s'opposer de manière de manière
considéré c'est du pragmatisme c'est du
bon sens et il faut une véritable
opposition parce que je crois
qu'aujourd'hui les français ont un petit
problème de lisibilité dans le
redécoupage de ce paysage politique
monsieur macron a réussi un exploit qui
l'atomiser un peu la droite d'atomiser
le parti socialiste afin les
républicains et les parties ciel et le
parti socialiste de l'autre côté plus
personne ne s'y retrouve vraiment
d'ailleurs on a un gouvernement un petit
peu patchwork
alors qui peut peut-être avoir des
avantages en terme de renouveau et
nouvelle approche total j'ai sans doute
mais voilà je crois surtout c'est que ce
gouvernement va nous emmener droit vers
l'austérité européisme forcené avec tous
les dégâts que c'est cesser ses méthodes
et ses politiques ont déjà démontré
depuis tant d'années on a aujourd'hui
beaucoup de français qui souffrent
beaucoup de français qui se sentent
oubliés qui sont oubliés et c'est à ces
gens là que je pense particulièrement et
c'est pour ça que ma candidature est une
candidature de conviction sur marche
poursuit avec vous en une minute à peu
près comme pour les autres candidats
pourquoi voter pour la france insoumise
bas d'abord parce que nous non plus nous
n'avons pas changé de programme entre
les présidentielles et les législatives
on s'adapte pas en charge pas de
conviction en moins d'un mois et donc
notre programme
eh bien il a réussi à bouleverser la
donne à mettre des sujets sur le tapis
parce qu'on disait que la compagnie
avait été polluée par des affaires mais
on a quand même réussi à parler de la
planification écologique du 100%
renouvelable et de deux
la sortie du nucléaire on a réussi par
les hologrammes parler aussi des
nouvelles technologies du numérique de
toutes les frontières de l'humanité
c'était des gadgets mais ça a permis de
mettre aussi des propositions font sur
sur la table donc porter ce programme
continue à le soutenir
et puis éviter aussi de donner les
pleins pouvoirs à macron parce que selon
nous il a été élu par défaut qu'une
majorité des français n'adhèrent pas à
son projet il n'a pas voté pour son
projet mais les a votés pour se
débarrasser des autres et donc il faut
savoir que si on n'est pas d'accord avec
le projet de d'emmanuel macro et bien on
peut lui donner une majorité alternative
une cohabitation et on propose la france
a soumises pour le parti socialiste à
présent jours alors pourquoi pourquoi
voter pour une candidate du parti
socialiste après le quinquennat qu'on a
eu
moi je vais continuer à défendre le
programme qui a été portée par notre
candidat benoît hamon qui était vraiment
un programme bienveillant et qui voilà
qui a mis aussi sur le devant de la
scène les enjeux sociaux la lutte des
classes l'écologie les urgences
sanitaires aussi avec les perturbateurs
endocriniens c'est super important de
pouvoir aussi continue à défendre ses
projets la taxe robot on en parle encore
le revenu universel on en parle encore
ce sont des projets qui malgré la
défaite de benoît hamon continue à être
discuté en france et puis même partout
partout ailleurs et je pense que les
français ont le droit d'avoir aussi des
des projets et des représentants
ambitieux et aussi des représentants qui
les représentent vraiment donc c'est à
dire des représentants qui connaissent
ce que c'est que d'avoir un emploi
salarié et de galérer à la fin du mois
d'être vraiment ancrée est ancré dans la
réalité tout le monde a le droit d'être
représentés et on n'est pas obligé
d'être représentés forcément que par la
même classe politique et pour terminer
ce premier tour de table avant de parler
d'éducation parce que s'il ya bien un
sujet qui divise l'ensemble des
candidats toutes formations toutes les
formations
c'est la question l'éducation olivier
paréja pour europe écologie
moi je suis convaincu qu'on a très peu
parlé d'écologie pendant la campagne
présidentielle et que c'est pourtant un
sujet majeur
il ya un sujet de transition il ya un
sujet transition énergétique mais aussi
les transitions au social il ya il ya
énormément de choses qui sont liées au
tour de l'écologie et c'est ce que je
voudrais porter personnellement je suis
très engagé depuis des années dans
certains collectifs associations sur
versailles sur saint quentin et on peut
le voir sur notre site internet où de
nombreux témoignages de gens engagés
d'experts sur certains sujets apportent
leur soutien à ma candidature parce que
finalement cette candidature avant
d'être politique elle elle le la
continuité des engagements des combats
que je porte depuis des années sur le
territoire
et c'est dans ce sens là que je voudrais
continuer nous allons donc parler à
d'éducation à présent des réformes sont
à venir dès les prochains mois le
nouveau ministre elle a annoncé est
d'ores et déjà des ajustements pour la
rentrée de septembre sont fort probable
on peut évoquer la fin du décret rendant
les redoublements exceptionnel une plus
grande autonomie donnée aux
établissements dans leur pédagogie ou
encore le dédoublement des classes de cp
dans les zones dites prioritaires didier
baichère je vais commencer avec vous et
puisque vous êtes le représentant du
nouveau président élu ses propositions
sur l'éducation aujourd'hui c'est un des
chantiers prioritaires il va falloir
aller aussi assez vite la rentrée pour
la rentrée que dans quelques mois
finalement si on veut faire quelques
ajustements fois que le ministre a une
approche très pragmatique sur le sujet
effectivement la rentrée approche à
grands pas et je pense que chacune des
communes où chacun des établissements
pour avoir aussi la capacité qu'il a
organisée vous avez cité 3 à 3 grands
exemples qui sont je pense au coeur du
programme il ya le dédoublement des
classes de cp et de ce1 dans les zones
d'éducation prioritaire il ya 2500
classes dédoublées qui ouvriront dès la
rentrée aujourd'hui on travaille et il
l'a très bien expliqué cette semaine on
travaille avec les différentes communes
pour voir en terme de locaux puisque
bien sûr qui dit dédoublement des
classes il faut avoir les locaux pour
pour les accueillir et donc la liste
aujourd'hui des 2500 classe nenê n'est
pas connue il ya un travail de fond qui
doit se mener on a parlé des rythmes
scolaires aussi la capacité vous savez
que ce débat était difficile dans nos
communes
je sais que montigny par exemple à
relancer un questionnaire ces derniers
jours dont ils ont à publier les
résultats et on voit l'insatisfaction
très grande des familles sur sur les
rythmes scolaires en tout cas de
montigny parce que j'ai vu qu il avait
lancé une consultation il faut pour les
communes qui sont en capacité d'être
prêt à la rentrée de pouvoir relancer la
concertation
si elle n'a pas lieu dans ce délai là ce
sera pour la rentrée prochaine si
l'adaptation est nécessaire puisque les
communes sont des approches variable du
sujet voilà un autre thème je pense
qu'il est important sur sur l'éducation
et qui nous tient particulièrement à
coeur c'est tout ce qui touche au tour
de l'orientation qu'il y ait évidemment
à l'autonomie des établissements
il faut que nous puissions mettre
l'orientation scolaire au collège comme
une matière d'enseignement fondamental
et nous avons beaucoup trop d'échecs sur
sur les orientations à partir du lycée
il faut vraiment que des professionnels
puissent rentrer dans les écoles de
manière j'ai envie d'être uniforme
puisque si vous êtes dans des zones
favorisées il ya déjà souvent des
parents qui viennent expliquer leur
métier il faut aller beaucoup plus loin
certaines équipes pédagogiques dans les
établissements ont du mal à avoir une
représentation des métiers variés et
pouvoir travailler cette orientation si
on en fait une matière scolaire on
pourra avoir
moi je pense à la réserve citoyenne qui
était pas forcément une si mauvaise idée
mais qui n'a pas été au bout est allé
piocher dans cette réserve citoyenne
pour faire les démonstrations françois
xavier lamy devrait vous faire réagir
parce que vous avez aussi fait de
l'éducation un des chantiers
prioritaires si jamais vous êtes élu je
peux citer quelques-unes des
propositions concentrer l'effort sur la
transmission des savoirs fondamentaux à
l'école primaire accroître l'autonomie
des chefs d'établissement par exemple
fait partie de votre programme comment
vous réagissez à ce qui est proposé et
qui pourrait être mise en place à part
l'équipe d' emmanuel macron je dirai
simplement trois choses d'abord la
première c'est que je crois que sur
l'éducation on est au coeur à l'heure
vous parliez de la question du rapport
que les députés de demain auront avec le
nouveau gouvernement
on est au coeur vraiment d'une question
sur laquelle justement on peut inventer
des coopération intelligente je crois en
effet que le ministre qui a été nommé
est quelqu'un de pragmatique qui nous
évitera sans doute les folies
idéologique auquel on a eu droit pendant
les cinq dernières années et donc sur ce
sujet là je crois que ce qui compte
c'est de pouvoir proposer des pistes
claire qui nous permettront demain
d'être transparent dans le fait que nous
soutiendrons ce qu'il ira dans le bon
sens par exemple le rétablissement des
classes bilangues leurs établissements
de l'enseignement des langues anciennes
mais qui nous permettra aussi
d'équilibrer les choses quand il faudra
le faire par exemple ce sera le cas je
pense à une mesure que je que je
regrette typiquement profondément qui
est la question du des doubles
on est des classes qui est vraiment une
mesure d'affichage tous les spécialistes
du sujet s'accordent à dire que ce n'est
pas par là que les choses se transforme
en profondeur la question qui compte
c'est la question des méthodes et la
question de la finalité même de l'école
et c'est parce que nous avons renoncé
comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire dans
un dans un ouvrage qui appelle les
déshérités parce que nous avons renoncé
à cette transmission des savoirs
fondamentaux
parce que nous avons adopté des méthodes
qui ne fonctionne pas que nous avons
nous même envoyé dans le mur des
générations d'élèves qui parce qu'ils
viennent de milieux sociaux défavorisés
c'est vrai ne bénéficient pas dans leurs
familles de cette familiarité avec la
culture scolaire qui a fait que d'autres
avaient pu s'en sortir et donc ça ne
change rien si vous avez des mauvaises
méthodes avec douze élèves ça ne
marchera pas mieux que quand vous avez
des mauvaises méthodes avec 24 élèves ce
qui compte c'est de retravailler sur ce
que doit faire l'école et la
transmission des savoirs me semble-t-il
doigts teintés de la priorité et puis là
la troisième chose que je voulais dire
c'est que si on pouvait revenir sur ce
sujet enfin à un peu de pragmatisme ce
serait effectivement très bien on
parlait tout à l'heure de société civile
je crois qu'il faut arrêter la démagogie
je pense que nous sommes tous ici de la
société civile moi même je suis
effectivement enseignant dans le
secondaire j'ai toujours voulu enseigner
la philosophie qui est une magnifique
discipline que j'ai enseigné au lycée
hôtelier de lui en cours non loin d'ici
et c'est vraiment sur le terrain je
crois que les vraies solutions se
construisent c'est sur le terrain qu'on
peut voir apparaître les vrais enjeux et
les vrais défis et de ce point de vue là
monsieur béchard je suis vraiment désolé
de vous le dire mais non malheureusement
l'orientation n'est pas la clé la clé
c'est que quand aujourd'hui dans notre
pays vous avez 15 % de jeunes qui
sortent de troisième sans savoir lire
correctement le français
vous pouvez faire tous les efforts que
vous voulez en matière d'orientation
vous n'arriverez pas à les sortir de la
difficulté ou encore une fois nous les
avons nous mêmes placés par
l'inefficacité de nos méthodes et je
suis très heureux de vous voir revenir
aujourd'hui sur la réforme des rythmes
scolaires que vous avez pourtant défendu
au conseil municipal de versailles dans
l'équipe socialiste que vous représentez
pour pouvoir justement faire avancer
mais c'est très intéressant de voir le
retournement de circonstance je vous
disiez tout à l'heure vous m'aviez parlé
de mazières qui ne voulaient pas
débattre pour mettre en place les
rythmes ska avait expliqué à la juge de
versailles le temps la ville de
versailles qui avait pris le temps de la
concertation avait expliqué qu'elles
étaient attentistes ce que je crois
aujourd'hui c'est que effectivement et
c'est une très bonne chose
emmanuel macron revient sur un certain
nombre d'erreurs qui ont été faites dans
les années précédentes que vous aviez
d'ailleurs soutenu je suis très heureux
de voir que précisément un peu de
pragmatisme ne fait de mal à personne en
tous les cas la vraie cohérence peut
être il faut la chercher dans le fil de
nos engagements respectifs va conserver
un tyran et lieu sur une ville comme
montini de manière précise dans la durée
ce n'est pas le cas à versailles
et c'est ça que j'ai combattu
dans tous les conseils d'école où les
élus sont présents monsieur vélo nissan
absolument farine de toute l'année je
vous interromps tous les deux pour
laisser la parole également aux autres
candidats qui bien sûr peuvent
intervenir n'hésitez pas je vous passe
la parole sur les différents sujets mais
n'hésitez pas à réagir comme ça puisse
produire ici et là je vous passe la
parole sur cette question scolaire dans
le programme notamment du du front
national y avait aussi la fin de la
réforme des rythmes scolaires
oui absolument alors je crois que
l'éducation est un point plus que
fondamental le mot fondamentale est un
peu un peu galvaudé la j'insiste dessus
parce que je crois que l'éducation c'est
vraiment le nerf de la guerre c'est à la
fois un élément de cohésion sociale
c'est un élément d'unité nationale est
rappelons le
l'école est là pour instruire le mot
éducation - me gêne un peu et si demain
je j'en avais la possibilité je
l'appellerai le ministère de
l'instruction nationale donc il faut
véritablement revenir aux fondamentaux
alors la colère on en a parlé une rom
non pas dessus mais revenir aux
fondamentaux et revaloriser tous types
de savoirs
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on a une
école pas aujourd'hui depuis
malheureusement un certain nombre
d'années on a une école qui cherche à
produire des des énarques des
polytechniciens des sciences po des
médecins des ingénieurs les et on en
oublie les savoirs manuel les savoirs
techniques qui sont complètement
complémentaire avec les savoirs
intellectuelle et tous ces savoirs là
doivent être valorisés dans l'école de
demain
je ne crois pas parce que ce que j'ai
entendu pour l'instant 2 du projet de
d'emmanuel macron c'est de la cosmétique
pour moi c'est à dire des doubles des
classes je ne crois pas deux secondes on
fait des choses ici ou là c'est la
cosmétique
alors qu'il faut véritablement revenir
aux fondamentaux de l'école et est ce
que disait monsieur bellamy tout à
l'heure c'est à dire que l'école doit
permet
tout simplement de d'apprendre à lire à
écrire à compter à savoir avoir de la
culture à connaître son histoire à
connaître sa géographie et tout ça ne me
semble absolument pas dans les tuyaux de
ce qui se prépare au ministère
l'éducation départ et je vous passe la
parole vous êtes le plus en retard et à
l'issue de cette thématique de
l'éducation on verra les chronomètres
s'afficher concernant les différentes
réactions vous pouvez avoir aussi sur ce
qui était alors sur l'éducation là où
vous rejoindrez certaines prises de
position c'est sûr le primaire je pense
qu'il est indispensable que dès le début
en investissent donc le fait de limiter
le nombre d'élèves dans les classes
d'éducation produire les zones
d'éducation prioritaire c'est quelque
chose de positif mais qu'il faudrait
voir à étendre dans l'intégralité du
territoire dans la mesure où pour un
instituteur selmouni institutrice dans
la plupart des cas c'est extrêmement
difficile d'être devant 25 26 élèves et
être capable dès le début des ce1 ce2 cp
d'être capable de transmettre leur
revient exactement soir on était 30 35
ans son arc mais je suis pas sûr qu'on
ait réussi
je ne suis pas sûr qu'on ait réussi à
faire front mais des gens ont
formidablement bien équipés
intellectuellement
aujourd'hui quand on regarde par exemple
les classements pisa y des choses de ce
type là ça nous montre que l'école
n'arrive pas à rectifier les inégalités
sociales de départ et c'est pas comme
aujourd'hui à une énième réforme qu'il
faut faire mais c'est vraiment donné les
moyens
je suis pas sûr que ce soit une question
de méthode que soit c'est une question
de principe qu'on essaye d'inculquer aux
élèves mais c'est avant tout une
question de moyens c'est à dire quand on
regarde ce qu'on dépense pour un élève
de primaire par rapport à ce qu'on
dépense sur un élève de secondaire ou
universitaires on voit que si
globalement on dépense la même chose que
les autres pays d'europe et la
répartition n'est pas du tout la même en
france on estime en investit pas
suffisamment en nombre d'enseignants en
coût par élève sur le primaire qui est
le début de la création de du savoir
thibault marshall pardon c'est à vous et
après ce sera au tour de la
représentante oui alors nous dans un
livret thématiques qu'on a développée en
par ce partenariat avec des spécialistes
et en complément de notre programme
dédié à l'école on revient sur notre
vision de la finalité de l'école l'école
d'abord pour nous elle doit être
républicaine et ça veut dire gratuites
mixte socialement laïque et neutre
y compris les pouvoirs économiques ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que si elle
est républicaine c'est la même pour tous
et l'autonomie des établissements c'est
une fausse bonne idée
c'est d école à deux vitesses ou à trois
vitesses
donc nous on est totalement content
c'est déjà tellement le cas aujourd'hui
si vous saviez oui ils et pourquoi pas
simple carte scolaire donc monnaie pour
un retour de la carte scolaire qui
garantissent la mixité sociale réelle
dans les classes donc la mixité d'agréer
des questions taille aussi c'est à dire
qu'à un moment le l'éducation nationale
c'est quelque chose qui est un petit peu
énorme et donc qu'il ya un cadre
national qui garantisse l'égalité tous
mais après qu'ils aient un petit peu
d'autonomie locale
c'est peut-être pas quelque chose de
négatif oui mais l'un des problèmes de
cette autonomie des établissements mise
à part le pouvoir très fort donné aux
chefs d'établissement c'est là qu'on
empiète justement sur les savoirs dont
on parlait tout à l'heure
l'école a pour finalité pour moi
d'éduquer des consciences des esprits
libres et autonomes et compenser aussi
un retard en matière de capital culturel
qui peut être transmis par les parents
et donc il faut que les os les
enseignements fondamentaux est un
horaire assuré or l'autonomie des
établissements consiste à donner un
volant d'heures que l'établissement
choisi on le pique aux français pourra
les mettre en enseignement en transe
machin truc projet bidule chouette et
finalement on n'est plus sûr qu'il ya un
certain nombre d'heures de français de
mathématiques etc etc
qu'il soit le même pour tous et qui est
une transmission culturelle qui soit la
même pour tous
en termes d'éléments de savoirs
fondamentaux je disais aussi la laïcité
c'est important pour nous pas un sou
public ne doit aller à l'enseignement
privé
si les gens veulent aller dans le privé
et bien il
finances d'accord ça garantit aussi d'un
mixte et dans l'enseignement public
et puis pour finir le l'autonomie
notamment avec la généralisation des
logiciels libres c'est absolument
problématique que nos élèves soient
formés à l'utilisation de certains
logiciels développés par certaines
multinationales surtout quand elles sont
américaines et qui ensuite sur le marché
du travail ne sont plus capables d'être
polyvalent donc il faut sortir
l'entreprise l'objectif n'est pas de
préparer de la main d'oeuvre pour les
entreprises l'objectif est de préparer
des citoyens polyvalent autonome adapté
à toute situation
chartres cet ennemi m'exécute alors êtes
vous d'accord avec plusieurs des choses
qui avait été dit en 1 8 mars qu on
partage on partage pas mal de pas mal de
choses mais bon ça c'est pas un secret
moi je voudrais juste revenir sur les
rythmes scolaires les rythmes scolaires
en fait il va y avoir une habile en
cours en 2018
donc je pense que voilà avant avant de
crier au laos cours haro sur les rythmes
scolaires candidat gbagbo avait aussi
porté cette réforme des régimes est
exactement donc on le voit sur la
circonscription de tumeurs il ya des
différences de politiques entre les
communes on voit qu'il ya des communes
où effectivement ça se passe très bien
parce qu'il ya une vraie volonté de la
mairie comme à guyancourt de porter ces
rythmes scolaires et de les assumer
c'est pas le cas dans toutes les
communes il faut savoir que cinq
matinées par semaine c'est bénéfique aux
enfants ils sont beaucoup plus
concentrés et le rythme surtout de lors
de leur semaine de classe n'est pas
coupé donc ça c'est primordial
pourtant dans les rythmes scolaires
ça ne peut marcher que s'il ya une
véritable concertation entre les
collectivités locales et les
associations et les enseignants et les
parents et c'est simplement c'est pas
simplement la ville qui fait des
animations au type club mickey ou je
sais pas quoi pour occuper les enfants
il faut absolument que y ait cette
coordination et il n'y a pas tant
d'exemples que ça qu'ils sont réalisés
encore une fois le rôle de l'école s'est
pas contenté d'expliquer ça te laisser
en place
j'entends de la différemment non non si
on apprend ainsi de manière extrêmement
basique aussi son retard à les aider il
ya des formes aussi d'éducation
parallèle qu'il faut aussi inclure dans
notre mode d'éducation
si je pense que c'est important et il
faut il faut aussi reconnaître la
différence entre les élèves tous les
élèves ne vont pas rentrer dans le moule
et donc c'est vraiment aussi important
de prendre cette cette différence que
tous les enfants peuvent avoir tous les
enfants ne vont pas à prendre on dit
même rythme tous les enfants ne vont pas
à prendre de la même manière et tous les
enfants surtout pas les mêmes les mêmes
chances d'une personne enfin un enfant
qui vient d'un milieu aisé qui part en
vacances ça qui va dans les musées qui
va au cinéma il avoir une ouverture
beaucoup plus facile et l'école est là
aussi pour gommer ces différences et
l'école doit aussi apporter la culture
parce que la culture si après
l'ouverture pour plein de gens plein de
choses après courir ici et c'est
incroyable d'entendre que l'école doit
aussi apporter la culture je crois qu'on
est en train de disserter sur l'école
comme si on parlait dans un dans un
salon d'une d'une réalité artistique
aujourd'hui l'école vit une tragédie
absolue ce sont des dizaines de milliers
d'enfants qui sont littéralement broyé
par le fait qu'on a effectivement
transformer les salles de classe en
annexe de la cour de récréation qu'on a
rompu avec l'idée de la transmission des
connaissances comme principe de
l'enseignement et que beaucoup
d'enseignants souffre profondément et
j'en suis moi même le témoin de cette
situation absurde dans laquelle on les
amis d'être les accompagnateurs de la
défaite de leurs institutions pour
laquelle ils ont engagé leur vie si on
peut rendre aux enseignants leur travail
refaire confiance alors savoir je crois
qu'on aura tout gagné embaucher du
personnel non mais c'est pas une
question de 60000 enseignants en plus si
on n'a jamais de quatre enseignants sur
la santé lise vous avez plus avant
sortant paroles qu'on va se voir
s'afficher dans un instant
moi pour moi fin c'est quelque chose qui
est super important c'est aussi
d'apporter cette chance que les enfants
peuvent avoir de développer lors leur
culture histoire qui puisse être des
citoyens complètement intégré il faut
aussi donc penser effectivement à la
mixité scolaire
il faut savoir que des classes où il y a
une vraie mixité sociale sont des
classes qui réussissent le mieux
donc il faut arrêter ces petits voilà
effectivement c'est ce que tu disais il
faut arrêter de 2,2 de couper les élèves
en fonction de l'heure de leurs milieux
sociaux et en fait enfin il est pour
finir chez moi il ya aussi quelque chose
qui est très important il faut aussi
s'occuper des élèves handicapés il faut
vraiment recruter du personnel compétent
et adéquate pour accompagner ces enfants
parce que c'est super compliqué quand
vous avez un enfant handicapé de pouvoir
le scolariser dans de bonnes conditions
et ça ça doit vraiment vraiment vraiment
être une priorité de notre prochain
enfin dans les prochains des notes
prises avait encore transept et ça passe
aussi l'aider clochardisation des
bâtiments oui à la rénovation des
bâtiments et loisirs tous les membres
actifs publics les métronomes tout
simplement amplement est accessible sur
notre cas pourraient très classe je
sorte à ce moment là emmanuel lacroix
avait dans son programme la la création
réelle d'une filière métier pour les
assistants handicapés enfin qui s'occupe
des handicapés sirleaf est et de l'est
de les titulariser et pas vivre ce qu'on
vit aujourd'hui terre qu'aujourd'hui les
familles change d'auxiliaires scolaire
tous les ans ne n'ont pas de raison d'en
changer parfois donc il ya vraiment la
nécessité de travailler c'est une armée
qui propose une chose c'est que puisque
l'état en ce moment achètent des hôtels
formule 1 pour y loger des migrants
mieux vaut les règles at il dit c'est
peut-être un autre sujet d utiliser ces
fonds non sans rejoue dans cet ancien
public c'est l'argent public sur
l'accession de l'éducation j'ai pas la
seule et vous et on valorise et sur une
seule sur un sujet qu'il n'était pas
keane qui n'était pas prévu on va voir
les temps de parole qui vont qui vont
s'afficher vous êtes tous eu plus ou
moins autour de 4 minutes alors temps de
paroles sont assez loin de moi je ne les
vois pas s'afficher
voilà ce que je sais c'est que olivier
par région vous avez plus de retard donc
c'est vous qui allez commencer à présent
dans la préparation de cette émission je
vous avais proposé de mettre en avant
une thématique une carte blanche la
thématique qui vous tenait le plus à
coeur on va faire ce tour de table on va
commencer avec vous donc olivier parages
a calé un petit peu le sujet que vous
entendez porter plus que les autres dans
cette danse est dans cette
circonscription je pense qu assez
logiquement je lui portais des sujets
qui tourne autour de la transition
écologique donc la transition écologique
et ça rebondit sur d'autres sujets qui
qui sont l'emploi par exemple donc la
transition écologique ça va être la
transition énergétique donc sortir des
énergies fossiles
sortir du nucléaire et ça on peut y
arriver dans des délais relativement
courts et imaginer qu'en 2050 on soit à
100% d'énergies renouvelables en france
et qu'on sorte du nucléaire vers 2025
2030 suivant suivant le plan
donc ça c'est des choses qui vont être
génératrice d'emplois aujourd'hui on
voit par exemple que sa chute un article
ce qui est paru cette semaine il ya plus
de 10 millions d'emplois dans les
énergies nouvelles dans le monde
ce cap a été franchi récemment et qu'on
voit que finalement les presque la
moitié sont en chine et plus de la
moitié en asie
ça veut dire que globalement on
investisse part en europe on n'investit
pas en france sur ces énergies nouvelles
qui seraient des filières à développer
des emplois à créer de la même façon on
peut développer aussi l'agriculture
l'agriculture biologique qui est elle
aussi en train d'augmenter et beaucoup
plus consommatrices d'emploi génératrice
d'emplois et c représentent aujourd'hui
près de 10% des emplois donc c'est la
transition énergétique c'est mieux pour
la planète au sens ça va limiter le
réchauffement climatique
donc ça va nous permettre de vivre mieux
demain pour nos enfants c'est meilleur
aussi pour la santé si on travaille sur
les transports on va limiter la
pollution qui est quand même un fléau en
ile de france où on a des pics de temps
en temps mais on a en dehors des
périodes de pic on a de la pollution en
permanence donc il ya des choses à faire
et qui sont en même temps génératrice
d'emplois est bonne pour la santé et qui
prépare qui préparent l'avenir non pas
de la planète qui sera toujours là mais
de nous deux vivent sur cette planète et
vivent en bonne intelligence avec le
monde entier car je ne rejoindrai pas
monsieur du front national
l'accueil des migrants aujourd'hui le
dérèglement climatique fait que
certaines zones du monde souffre déjà de
sécheresse souffre déjà de
désertification et ces gens là se
retrouvent dans des situations tellement
pas possible qu'ils génèrent soit des
conflits soient des migrations massives
il faut aussi que quelque part on est
une ambition importante de corriger ses
effets et de développer des fonds de
compensation dans ces pays là pour
corriger un peu ce que nous pays
industrialisés industrialisés avons fait
de la planète
je vous pas justement la parole je
précise que vous trop de cette carte
blanche vous pouvez aussi intervenir si
vous souhaitez réagir sur ce qui a été
dit et ensuite moi j'avais désormais de
j'avais aussi envie de parler de
l'écologie parce que en effet et là je
sais le seul point sur lequel je suis
d'accord avec monsieur par hasard mais
nous avons peu parlé d'écologie
or c'est un sujet un sujet éminemment
important mais je crois que l'écologie
c'est avant tout finalement ça revient
au patriotisme économique
l'écologie ça consiste en dans un
premier temps à consommer et à produire
au plus près de la consommation est une
arène d'accord couper du bois dans les
vosges l'envoyait le bout du monde pour
le transformer et le renvoyer par bateau
à paris pour être vendus dans des
magasins à paris en france c'est
totalement absurde
totalement absurde donc le patriotisme
économique c'est un exemple bien
évidemment il y en a plein d'autres mais
je crois que le patriotisme économique
est quelque chose qui nous remet très
bien les pieds sur terre je pourrais
très bien en alsace 1 c'est plus simple
d'aller chercher des choses en allemagne
que d'aller en bretagne
donc le patriote le local ne s'arrête
plus importante et à semer panique ce
n'est pas que ça le patriotisme
économique qui a le mot est à 2002 dans
qu'est ce qu'on veut me donner lloris
mme vous arrêter à la frontière de la
france
absolument non seulement ce qui est
absolument pas écologique
si je dis au chocolat par exemple en
alsace et à 100 km 12 km le débat n'est
pas là mais aussi contre lavaur
personnellement c'est 80 km à un truc
dans la définition de gabor km autour de
la défendre l'économie de notre pays je
vous rappelle qu'on a 7 millions de
chômeurs qu'on a quasiment 10 millions
de pauvres qui a 10 millions de
personnes qui tous les jours se
demandent ce qu'ils vont pouvoir manger
le lendemain tous les moyens le
patriotisme économique c'est un nombre
donné donné la priorité à notre pays à
nos industries à nos entreprises a noté
paix à nos pme qui sont fortement
créatrices qui ont des capacités
phénoménales aujourd'hui en france on va
tous les talents qu'il faut pour tous
fabriqués tout construire tout imaginer
revenons les pieds sur terre
sur ce sur ce sujet là et arrêtons cette
mondialisation qui est en train de nous
broyer tous certains sans s'en rendre
compte
simon marshall c'est à vous avez à peu
près à peu près deux minutes pour les
autres ce sera au tour du d'une minute
un peu plus pour sur votre septième j'y
reviendrai et puis ensuite on passera
aux conclusions parce qu'il faut avancer
et il ya d'autres candidats qui vont
venir nous rejoindre après alors moi
même je voulais parler surtout du social
et de la loi enfin de la loi de
l'ordonance qui vise à faire une loi une
connerie xxl et à précariser encore les
travailleurs et à revenir sur le droit
du travail
donc nous évidemment ce que l'on propose
celle inverse c'est d'abord l'abrogation
de la nouvelle connerie c'est une un
travail en intelligence dans
l'entreprise avec de nouveaux droits
pour les salariés la démocratie
aujourd'hui elle s'arrête aux portes de
l'entreprise on dit en économie qui a
deux facteurs de production le travail
et le capital
sauf qu'on voit que ceux qui prennent
les décisions ce sont les propriétaires
du capital
les les représentants des travailleurs
sont consultés et n'ont pas de poids de
décision dans l'entreprise c'est un
problème
ya pas de démocratie est réel dans
l'entreprise c'est un c'est un problème
pour nous dans la sixième république
on propose que les salariés soit
impliqué dans l'entreprise et 7 qu'on
propose la concertation le dialogue la
démocratie partout tout le temps est
passé en ordonnance ou en 49 3 celle
inverse de la démocratie nous aurons à
noter 49,3 ordonnance c'est pas la même
chose tout à fait mais c'est intéressant
parce que juste une aparté us comme chez
des rats je me sens un peu voilà vous
savez que le même temps de parole après
pour la carte ne savait que le syndicat
qui signe le plus d'accords d'entreprise
et le syndicat qui ne signe jamais rien
aux centrales au niveau national le
syndicat qui est le plus revendicatif de
manière visible dans les rues en france
au niveau national et le syndicat qui a
bien compris que les accords
d'entreprise c'est ce qui faisait la
différence pour les salariés donc je
pense que c'est des vérités qu'il faut
aussi entendre à un moment donné et ne
pas être dogmatique sur ses positions
l'accord d'entreprise les syndicats
ils font la démocratie mon truc et
l'échafaud restait que quelques secondes
ans martial voulez skier
l'idée c'est d'apporter de nouveaux
droits de revenir à la retraite à 60 ans
avec 40 annuités
c'est un protectionnisme solidaires 7 c
sortir du nucléaire du diesel d eux des
ogm comme nous le propose macron c'est
refuser la hausse de la csg qui va
réduire les pensions
c'est refuser la pression sur les
chômeurs qui doivent absolument accepter
une offre d'emploi ou de la deuxième
sinon ils n'ont plus rien c'est refuser
les politiques d'austérité et tous les
traités européens qui permettent par
exemple les travailleurs détachés qui ne
sont ni profitable aux européens
travailleurs européens qui finalement en
souffrent dans leur vie sociale et
familiale
même s'ils gagnent plus d'argent et les
travailleurs français qui en souffrent
également très bien vous c'est parfait
vous êtes arrêté comme il faut aux 7 à 5
minutes 15 de temps de parole cinq
minutes 18 pour thierry pérez et pour
viser par déjà cinq minutes trente sur
l'autre cet hymne c'est à vous une
minute trente ce serait parfait et ce
sera une minute chacun ensuite pour
monsieur bellamy et messieurs mes chers
avant de passer à votre conclusion à
chacun engagés moi j'aurais pu parler
aussi effectivement de la loi travail de
l'écologie sachant qu on a quand même un
gouvernement qui n'est pas vraiment pro
écologie on l'a bien vu avec la
nomination d'un premier ministre qui est
quand même pro-nucléaire on a bien vu
aussi pendant les prises de position
pendant la présidentielle de d'emmanuel
macron qui est quand même pour l'élevage
intensif qui est pour la chasse alors
moi qui suis militante pour la cause
animale c'est des questions qui me qui
me touche à beaucoup qui ont voir la
chaussée va être au top sur le plan
écologique
mais bon on en reparlera après bien sûr
le pas du tout mais bon bref
donc moi je vais vous parler aussi d'un
sujet qui est super important qui en
sont un sujet de santé publique si les
perturbateurs endocriniens encore vu
aujourd'hui
la commission européenne va voter là
donc bon échelon l'aele et la
possibilité de relancer la procédure
d'autorisation
du principal composant du art il faut
savoir que le round up si c'est
dangereux il ya beaucoup d'ardeur buteur
exactement et il sera désormais il ya
des augmentations de cancer il ya la
maladie d'alzheimer aussi et il ya
surtout exactement c'était ma phrase
d'après monsieur vous si vous pouviez
arrêtez de couper la gente féminine
serait simple donc voilà propre puberté
précoce aussi chez les enfants que c'est
c'est super c'est super grave c'est un
vrai vrai vrai problème de santé
publique
savoir que les perturbateurs
endocriniens vous les avez partout dans
les cosmétiques dans les appareils
électroniques et surtout dans les
limitations il faut vraiment agir au
niveau européen instauré un grand plan
de recherche partager aussi avec les
autres pays à nos avancées il faut
vraiment complexifier aussi les tests et
surtout surtout surtout surtout
interdire interdire interdire les
perturbateurs nos clients enfin je vous
trouve très tolérante là dessus parce
que vous avez voulu cette union
européenne vous l'avez imagine
européenne l'union européenne a dit
effectivement aujourd'hui où vous verrez
temps pour conclure sa liste en mai a
dit le rapport des experts sur les
perturbateurs endocriniens double arrêt
non non c'est bien pour l'europe
je disais donc françois-xavier bellens
est à vous quel est votre carte blanche
le sujet sur lequel vous allez mettre
l'accent pendant là c'est jour de
campagne qui reste il y aurait tellement
de sujets sur lesquels il faut si
j'étais très heureux qu'on parle
d'éducation parce que je crois vraiment
que c'est vraiment le sujet majeur pour
l'avenir de notre pays
mais s'il fallait parler d'un autre
sujet qui me paraît vraiment décisif
c'est la question de l'emploi
aujourd'hui on est vraiment au bord de
la rupture et on l'a vu à l'occasion de
ces élections présidentielles où les
français ont voté en quelque sorte
malheureusement les uns contre les
autres par classe sociale par milieux
sociaux plutôt qu'autour de projets je
crois que fondamentalement nous
n'arriverons pas à déverrouiller ce
frein qui pèsent sur notre pays si nous
ne libèrerons pas d'abord les capacités
des entreprises à investir à agir à
recruter et ça ça ne se décrète pas
malheureusement on ne décrète pas la
création d'emplois on ne peut que la
servir aujourd'hui l'état est devenu le
premier boulet de ceux qui dans notre
pays crée de l'activité
je le vis moi même comme président de la
mission locale je m'occupe tous les
jours de ces décès de ces centaines de
jeunes que la mission locale de
versailles et des environs accompagne
aujourd'hui beaucoup d'entre nous
n'arrivent pas à rentrer dans le monde
du travail
parce que le
la france est le pays qui charge le plus
le travail c'est le 115e pays sur 138
qui complique le recrutement qui
complique le fait de maintenir et de
développer une activité est donc
aujourd'hui malheureusement alors que
nous avons des millions de chômeurs dans
notre pays
eh bien nous sommes incapables de
libérer les efforts de nos entreprises
de libérer les efforts de tous ceux qui
dans notre pays pourrait créer de
l'activité
c'est la condition vraiment pour que
nous puissions refaire demain une
société solidaire et c'est ce dont nous
avons vraiment le risque de revenir sur
les charges des entreprises c'est dire
l'éternel le light motif la croissance
la croissance la croissance mais cette
croissance déjà on ne l'a pas connue
depuis des années 60 donc l'a rêvée pour
demain c'est totalement illusoire et il
faut quand même savoir que la plupart
des emplois qu'on perd ce n'est pas des
délocalisations mais c'est
principalement aux trois quarts
c'est de la productivité c'est de la
robotisation c'est de l'automatisation
je finis mon entraînement en deux mots
en deux mots la seule façon d'arriver à
ne pas faire un monde où d'un côté on a
des riches qui ont du travail et de
l'autre on a toute une série de
laissés-pour-compte de travailleurs
précaires c'est de partager le travail
qu'il y a en conséquence de la
productivité keeps niveau international
puisque deux mots je le donne rdv chez
excusez moi didier baichère
passionnerait un débat juste sur
l'emploi parce que j'aurais fait on
essaie de le faire sur les duels
je voulais laisser le temps de choisir
une carte blanche
rapidement ce que c'est le cinquième
point de mon programme pour la
circonscription et jeux olympiques parce
que c'est quelque chose de fédérateur
c'est une ce sera un grand événement
familial
on sait aussi qu'en termes
d'infrastructures c'est quelque chose
qui est qui est extrêmement intéressant
et on a dans les yvelines 108 sportifs
de haut niveau donc ce qui nous ce qui
nous met sur le podium de manière assez
intéressante et donc je moi je
m'investirai personnellement dans ce
dossier on a la chance d'être la
circonscription on va avoir sur chacune
de nos trois villes et encore une
épreuve des jo de l'histoire avec le
golf le golf le vélo à montigny et le
cheval à versailles donc voilà une belle
fête populaire je pense que on pourrait
être pire si on obtient des jeux
olympiques et on y contribuera dans la
circonscription de manière importante et
vous n'êtes pas du tout d'accord on
l'avait repris sur le bout de la table
ont la bougeotte et la pragmatique à
vous savez donc fédérer je sais ce que
ça veut dire
voilà un événement
fellows et dans les anciennes villes qui
n'a pas regardé le vélodrome en 2012 il
était construit marre je te retrouve les
jo mais qu'on écoute à l'agglomération
de 51,6 hausse reste rien de soyaux gêne
et vous serez invités lorsque nous
organisons cette émission réservée aux
yeux suivent reclus ne le verdict pour
les jeux en 2d 700 dont je rappelle
qu'il reste la ville de la candidature
de paris auquel s'attend si green
versailles et s'est associé est aussi
los angeles c'est selon les dernières
rumeurs paris était plutôt en bonne
position voilà pour finir le dossier
jeux olympiques
la conclusion à une vingtaine de
secondes chacun s'il vous plaît et vous
serez à peu près à 6 minutes et l'équité
sera puisqu'il respecte et olivier parer
à une vingtaine de secondes s'il vous
plaît pour conclure si vous si on le
ferait pour conclure enfin moi je vois
bien aujourd'hui que il y a plusieurs
propositions qui sont franchement
différentes d'un côté on veut continuer
dans les vieilles recettes de et il ya
des autres propositions alternatives en
particulier porté par des députés
écologistes qui vont vers un partage
vers plus de solidarité et vers plus
d'écologie et c'est bon pardon c'était
juste le moment de la conclusion ou
l'asie je recommençais n'ont donc je
disais oui que c'est bien avec plus de
démocratie locale il ya des tonnes
d'aidés initiative citoyenne qui pallie
au manque de volonté de tous les
politiques qu'on connaît et sait mais
ces initiatives citoyennes il faut les
porter à l'assemblée nationale et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut des députés
écologistes pour le parti socialiste
c'est notre c'est signé oui il a même de
seconde par seconde maximum conclusion
vraiment qu'on appelle aussi notre
notamment politiques
il va falloir vraiment aussi que les
politiques et le prochain député de la
circonscription et un discours
bienveillant et apaisée il faut vraiment
qu'on redonne confiance à nos
concitoyens qui publie ce vraiment
s'engager et voilà qui est vraiment un
vrai renouvellement et qu'on arrête
aussi de nous dire que le renouvellement
ça passe par des personnes qui sont
forcément
déjà l'élu chaque citoyen à sa place à
l'assemblée nationale les employés ce
qui touche le smic on a tous le droit
d'être représentés marshall pour la
france insoumise il conclut en disant
que je me demande quelles sont les
priorités de son gouvernement dans les
premières semaines de son mandat est ce
que c'est lutter contre la pauvreté
lutter contre l'urgence écologique non
se détricoter le code du travail
rien sur un investissement massif de
l'état pour créer des emplois dans les
frontières de l'humanité dans
l'agriculture dans la mer dans l'espace
dans le numérique
il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de grand
emprunt comme nous le proposons dans
l'avenir en commun thierry pérez
nationale écoutez bouger l'on dit dire
que je voudrais donner par nouveau front
national je dois donner espoir aux
français parce que je suis assez inquiet
pour eux lorsque je vois ce qui se
profile dans les mois et les années qui
viennent
monsieur macron considère la france
comme un pays de consommateurs
considèrent la france non pas comme un
pays mais comme un territoire d'un
marché et je suis extrêmement inquiète
de ce qui va se passer dans les mois et
les années qui viennent voyons depuis
quinze jours le président emmanuel
macron à l'oeuvre et je crois que la
france est de retour sur la scène
internationale c'est je pense qu'on peut
avoir beaucoup de fierté de ce qu'on
vient de voir ces derniers jours la
presse internationale est unanime par
rapport à l'action de notre gouvernement
on a fait ce qu'on a dit qu'on ferait on
a un gouvernement d'union nationale qui
est à l'oeuvre qui travaille rapidement
et ça je pense que c'est une vraie
garantie par contre si on veut mettre en
place le plan de transformation sur
lequel emmanuel macron s'est engagé il
faut une majorité forte à l'assemblée
nationale tout ce qui ressemblerait à ce
que nous connaissons depuis 30 ans et
bricoler et s'arranger avec d'autres
partis ne permettra pas de transformer
la française
il faut donner il faut donner une
majorité à emmanuel macron et donc voter
de la république en marche et
françois-xavier bellamy
bon je vois c'est que dans cette
élection il faut que les gens puissent
voter pour les idées qui leur
appartiennent il faut proposer un projet
qui soit transparent cohérent puisque
demain leur voix soit portée au
parlement de façon bienveillante
constructive intelligente mais en
assurant aussi cet équilibre
démocratique et la condition de notre
vie institutionnelle de notre vie
parlementaire
le l'efficacité d'un gouvernement n'a
jamais été lié au fait de détenir un
parti unique et je crois que ce dont
nous avons besoin aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment de ce pluralisme intelligent
bienveillant mais qui sont en même temps
la condition de cet équilibre dont nous
avons vraiment besoin et c'est sur le
terrain qu'il se construit merci à tous
les six d'avoir participé à cette
première partie de débat concernant la
première circonscription sous pouvoir
les temps de paroles qui s'affichent
olivier par ailleurs vous avez le plus
de retard finalement vous êtes parmi les
premiers avec six minutes 52 de temps de
parole je rappelle que c'est l'équité 1
qui s'applique comme le recommande le
csa et que ça s'équilibre aussi avec les
différents reportages que nous
consacrons à cette campagne au cours de
nos éditions du journal
dans les autres émissions également
merci à tous les six l'émission 7,8
débat concernant 7,8 politique débat
concernant la première circonscription
va se poursuivre dans un instant juste
après ce reportage rappelant les
principaux enjeux dans la première
circonscription l'échiquier politique de
la première circonscription va-t-il
basculer c'est la question qui se pose
depuis le départ annoncé le 23 janvier
dernier du député dvd sortant françois
de mazières
l'homme politique en place depuis 2012
sur cette circonscription qui regroupe
une partie de versailles montigny le
bretonneux lui en cours ne se
représentera pas pour se consacrer
exclusivement à son mandat de maire sur
la cité versaillaise ce dernier laisse
la place à une nouvelle génération de
politiciens sur le secteur et la lutte
pour sa succession s'annonce ouverte
quatorze candidats se sont lancés pour
emporter la circonscription bastion
d'une droite traditionnelle ou françois
fillon réalisé 43 % des suffrages au
premier tour de la présidentielle à
versailles et où françois de mazières a
été élu avec 56% des voix au second tour
en 2012
françois-xavier bellamy candidats les
républicains est annoncée comme le
favori de ces élections dans une
circonscription avec 38 bien que 6 % des
cadres en milieu urbain et qui votent à
droite depuis 1963
adoubé par le maire de versailles ce
professeur de classe préparatoire à
paris âgée de 31 ans est adjoint chargé
de la jeunesse et de l'enseignement
supérieur dans la cité royale
son principal adversaire devrait être
didier baichère l'homme de la république
en marche à versailles
rallié de la première heure au nouveau
président de la république pourrait
surfer sur la dynamique emmanuel macron
est en train de convaincre une
population aisée avec un revenu médian
mensuel de 2440 euros autre outsider
pour la députation le front national
troisième dans la circonscription en
2012 avec ses 2 94% des voix le parti de
marine le pen a également réalisé 23 85%
des suffrages au deuxième tour de la
présidentielle
siri perez chef d'entreprise de 50 ans
espère donc réaliser un bon score pour
le fn
pour cela il misera sur les 8,2 pour son
2 chômage la circonscription et un taux
de pauvreté de 12 4%
de son côté le parti socialiste espère
faire aussi bien qu'en 2012 ou isabelle
this-saint-jean s'était hissé au 2e tour
face à françois de mazières mais
s'étaient inclinés à 43 3% des voix pour
faire aussi bien le ps a investi
charlotte rossetti ni 31 ans qui vit à
versailles a fait ses études à montigny
l'aube retenues
mais le parti socialiste a moins la cote
sur la circonscription qui compte un peu
plus de cent trente deux mille habitants
la france insoumise représenté pendant
la présidentielle par jean luc mélenchon
pourrait cette fois ci terminé devant le
ps comme aux présidentielles à verser à
guyancourt et à montigny le bretonneux
le jeune thibault marchal sera le
candidat du parti enfin neuf autres
candidats seront également dans la
course la droite conservatrice sera
représenté par françois billot de
lochner nicolas jacquot carmichaël
candidat dvd se présentera aussi pour le
siège de député on retrouvera emmanuel
bojan jean-loup leroux nicolas robin
plis nat geneviève que je skie olivier
paréja paul de béton et florence imbert
l'échiquier politique le débat du
premier tour se poursuit sur cette
première circonscription des yvelines ce
sont à présent quatre nouveaux candidats
qui nous ont rejoins nous accueillons à
présent à nicolas jacquot carmichaël
vous êtes candidat dans cette 1re
circonscription divers droite à nicolas
robin li na de face à vous pour l'upm
emmanuel bojan pour debout la france et
geneviève et que geof ce qui pour le
petit quizz français merci à tous les
quatre et bonsoir
la règle est la même que sur la première
partie de l'émission le temps de parole
est chronométré vous pourrez changer les
uns avec les autres premier tour de
table et cette question là même que tout
à leur simple pourquoi les électeurs
doivent devrait vous faire confiance
pour ce vote
la première chose je crois c'est qu'ils
doivent aller voter indépendamment de
voter pour moi ils doivent aller voter
parce que je
appellerait à tout le monde que le
premier parti de france aujourd'hui
c'est des abstentionnistes les votes
blancs et c'est grave et c'est pour ça
que j'ai un site tout le monde allait
voter
ensuite pourquoi voter pour moi parce
que je suis un candidat indépendant
c'est-à-dire qui ne dépend pas d'un
parti qui ne dépend pas d'une ligue
directrices fixées par d'autres qui ne
dépend pas d'un groupe de pression de
lobbys et caetera et qui est ancré dans
la vie civile dans le sens où depuis 25
ans je suis commerçant motivante
xhonneux né à versailles et au quotidien
je j'entends je réagis à la vie
quotidienne des français et je crois
qu'un candidat qui sait ce que c'est que
la vie des français est à même de
proposer ou de corriger ce que les
députés auront à faire pendant la
récession
clinact pour l'upm bonsoir je vais me
présenter je suis versaillais j'ai fait
mes études de la maternelle au lycée une
classe préparatoire à saint germain en
laye une matière à sainte-geneviève puis
j'ai fait l'école des ponts et chaussées
après j'ai passé l'agrégation de
mathématiques et j'ai enseigné dans les
landes puis en guyane en 2012 mon père a
eu un très grave avc et j'ai choisi de
me mettre en disponibilité pour
m'occuper de lui à plein temps ce que
j'ai fait jusqu'à son décès le 17 mars
au cours des heures que je passais
auprès de lui j'ai découvert l'union
populaire républicaine républicaine par
le biais d'une conférence de son
président fondateur françois asselineau
que j'ai rejoint au bout d'un an j'ai
pris la responsabilité de la délégation
des yvelines un an après et dans la
continuité de cet engagement je suis
maintenant candidat dans la première
circonscription alors pourquoi voter
pour moi déjà parce que mon casier
judiciaire est vierge
on exige de chacun de nos candidats
ensuite parce que je connais bien les
sujets auxquels je suis attaché à savoir
les questions bien sûr d'éducation ça je
suis content que ce soit un thème que
vous proposiez ce soir puisque j'y ai
enseigné dans les landes puis en guyane
et ensuite parce que suivant l'article 4
de la constitution
les partis politiques présentent une
diversité d'opinions et je pense que
nous ne sommes pas dans une pensée
unique et qu'il est intéressant de faire
connaître à l'ensemble des français des
analyses que développe l'union populaire
républicaine
enfin savoureux debout la france et
manuel bojan bonsoir moi j'ai 34 ans je
suis journaliste
je viens de versailles et je pense qu'il
est important d'apporter un
contre-pouvoir à l'assemblée nationale
d'apporter aussi à la représentation
nationale des des personnes 9
je suis quelqu'un de d'intègre et il me
semble que il faudrait des personnes qui
soient fernand tant que députés pour
défendre à la fois l'identité de la
france la grandeur de la france et puis
aussi savoir se défendre ne pas entrer
dans des compromissions avec le
gouvernement avec des avec des lobbys et
pouvoir aussi se battre contre le
communautarisme et pour conclure ce
premier tour de table
c'est un rite vieille abschied donc je
suis candidate pour le parti communiste
français
alors pourquoi voter pour une candidate
du parti communiste parce que vous aurez
une députée qui luttent sans cesse
contre les inégalités sociales une
députée qui défendra le maintien et le
développement des services publics de
qualité avec les moyens nécessaires en
personnel et en matériel car seuls les
services publics garantissent la vraie
égalité de tous les citoyens sur le
territoire merci pour ce premier tour de
table est maintenant bojan je vais
commencer avec vous c'est vous qui avez
le mot parler pour jusqu'à présent elle
la thématique ce sera la même que sur la
première partie de cette émission je le
rappelle nous avons dû scinder cette
émission aux trois gros puisqu'il y
avait de nombreux candidats sur cette
circonscription 14 et ne pouvons pas
accueillir vous le voyez bien plus de 5
6 personnes simultanément veuillez nous
en excuser
mais on veille à ce que ce soit une
équité maximum et que chacun puisse
s'exprimer dans les mêmes conditions
concernant l'éducation puisque c'est la
thématique qui a été retenu j'aimerais
avoir vos la différentes propositions
pour debout la france
il est question de reconstruire l'école
du savoir notamment ça signifie quoi non
ça signifie qu'on a vécu pendant des
années avec les ravages du pédagogisme
et de programmes scolaires qui était qui
allait vers 1
un nivellement vers le bas j'ai
l'impression que le niveau du bac
actuelle est inférieur à celui du brevet
des collèges des années 80 et il me
semble qu'il faut ressusciter les
savoirs fondamentaux je vois que dans
certaines filières on a désormais plus
que deux heures de français ou deux
heures de mathématiques ça me paraît
complètement aberrant et je ne pense pas
que ce soit rendre service à nos enfants
que de les priver des des savoirs
fondamentaux je suis favorable à une
école de la république laïque à la
méritocratie et on assiste désormais à
de plus en plus de d'exil d'enfants vers
le vers le privé et je suis favorable à
l'école de la république public et il
faut en ce sens ressuscité donc les
savoirs fondamentaux et et je pense que
il faut aussi mieux connaître son
histoire ce qu'on peut pas savoir où on
va si on ne sait pas d'où l'on vient
donc en signer davantage l'histoire à
signer davantage le français puisqu'on
ne peut pas maîtriser le monde si l'on
ne domine pas sa langue maternelle gay
prend plusieurs propositions et
plusieurs changements qui pourraient
survenir avec l élection d' emmanuel
macron la fin du décret sur le
redoublement qui rendait rend doublement
exceptionnelle pardon une plus grande
autonomie aussi aux établissements j'ai
moi aussi avoir le sentiment aux uns et
aux autres sources qui éventuellement
pourraient se mettre en place
revenir sur les rythmes scolaires aussi
très bonne chose oui il me semble qu'il
ya une mesure qui va dans le bon sens
déjà pour rétablir davantage de savoirs
fondamentaux au cpe est aussi un afin
que les élèves sachent rapidement lire
et écrire qu'en ce qui concerne les
rythmes scolaires mais je pense qu'il
faut le rythme qui est nécessaire pour
l'enfance si on a une semaine qui est
qui est longue et qu'on travaille par
exemple le samedi matin ça ne me semble
pas un problème s'il est si les matières
sont bien réparties je pense que dans
les dernières années on a trop fait
attention aux parents d'élèves pour
qu'on leur préserve des week-ends le
plus important ça reste l'enfant et son
émancipation
geneviève kossowski sur cette question
de l'éducation peut-être vos réactions à
ce qui a été dit ok
alors pour l'éducation notre ambition
c'est d'avoir la même école pour tous et
par tous ne vont pas d'une société
fragmentée où règne la peur de l'autre
et la concurrence généralisée et c'est
ce que a tendance à faire l'école
aujourd'hui l'école doit construire une
culture commune à tous et nous demandons
donc une augmentation du budget de
l'éducation nationale alors que les
écoles les classes sont surchargées
qu'il manque partout des enseignants des
médecins des infirmières scolaires des
conseillers d'orientation
on va nous parler de suppressions de
postes est donc c'est pas compatible
avec une éducation dans de bonnes
conditions
tout ce qui a été avancé peut-être aussi
par un maniaque rouge j'en parlais tout
à l'heure les rythmes scolaires les
rythmes scolaires
ça a été déjà difficile en étant place
je pense que ça va mettre pas mal de
communes aux difficultés alors qu'ils
ont investis pour pour rentrer dans
cette réforme alors après lille ce
serait laisser le choix aux communes
cette voie là écoutez si ce choix mais
bon c'est une question de moyens et je
pense que il ya beaucoup de choses qui
va tourner autour des moyens mis en
oeuvre nous on veut que les que chaque
enfant ait la même chance au départ et
les mettent les moyens qui vont bien
s'il des doubles des classes mais qui
supprime des postes ailleurs qui fait ça
va pas vraiment régler le problème
nicolas jacques rocca quelles sont vos
propositions 577 pour la france qui qui
vous soutient dans ce scrutin à
plusieurs propositions revaloriser le
métier d'enseignant expérimenter de
nouvelles pédagogies aussi alors je
crois qu'il faut remettre l'enseignement
c'est une donnée essentielle donnée
essentielle parce que des enfants formés
ce sont des enfants qui réfléchissent ce
sont des enfants qui arrivent à faire la
part du bien et du mal ce sont des
enfants qu'on évitera de voir prendre
des chemins de traverse et notamment
ceux plus radicaux je pense aux nombreux
terroristes qui viennent d'eux qu'ils
sont passés à l'école de la france la
première chose j'ai envie de dire c'est
de reprendre les choses à la base
responsabiliser les responsabiliser les
parents chacun doit reprendre son rôle
l'école n'a pas pour but de donner une
éducation elle a pour but de donner un
enseignement donc les parents il faut
les responsabiliser
ensuite au niveau des propositions de
monsieur macron il est important de ne
pas tout changer tout le temps c'est à
dire que tout modifier systématiquement
je crois que pour le corps enseignant
comme pour les enfants la stabilité est
impérative
le changement de programme les réformes
tous les ans les grandes lois
ministériel ça suffit un ovni il faut
donner un cadre évidemment les savoirs
ou les enseignements fondamentaux sont
essentiels un enfant qui a du mal à
comprendre et à lire le français ne sera
jamais un bon mathématicien parce qu'il
aura du mal à lire un énoncé autre chose
très important ne pas oublier que dans
le processus de l'élu qui donne de
l'enseignement d'après la maternelle
joue un rôle essentiel et dans la
maternelle un rôle essentiel c'est celui
des atsem
je pense qu'il faut faire très attention
et crée un statut et une filière de
formation spécifiquement pour les atsem
qui accompagne nos enfants en bas âge
systématiquement et qui sont à la base
de la sociabilisation des enfants
socialisation ça veut dire capacité de
s'intégrer dans la société
donc c'est une donnée essentielle
ensuite de mon expérience à moi avec mes
propres enfants je dirais qu'il faut un
gros focus sur l'apprentissage
l'apprentissage doit presque devenir une
norme parce que des enfants enfin où des
ados ou des jeunes adultes formés mais
n'ayant aucune connaissance du monde
réel du monde de pratiques des
entreprises ne seront jamais bien
employé du côté de lui payer aussi pas
mal de propositions concernant
l'éducation et vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure c'est un thème aussi que vous
personnellement si vous êtes élu député
vous entendre et défendre
tout à fait je vais parler un petit peu
de mon expérience en guyane et dans les
landes ce que j'ai remarqué c'est que
sauf exception les enfants qui
réussissent c'est les enfants dont les
parents sont derrière je pense par
exemple à jean marc cosset tout courant
que j'avais en classe de seconde à au
lycée bertène juminer air de saint
laurent du maroni dont le père ne
parlait pas français et qui étaient
terrorisés à l'idée que j'écrive un mot
dans son carnet miss kiss avec son père
le soir lui demanderais qu'est ce qu'il
a écrit là ton prof traduit mois voilà
j'avais aussi un autre élève que j'en
voyais en classe préparatoire
jean-philippe compay à mana sur la côte
en guyane également dont le père parlait
à peine français
d'ailleurs le ministre actuel du
gouvernement philippe 1 était recteur de
la guyane entre entre 2004 et 2006 et
j'observe que dans le gouvernement
actuel il n'y a plus de ministre de la
famille madame rossignol qui était
ministre des familles sous le
gouvernement de monsieur cazeneuve le
poste n'existent plus donc je pense
comme disait monsieur tout à l'heure
qu'il faut absolument responsabiliser
les parents vous parlez des rythmes
scolaires j'en parlerais parce que c'est
un petit peu l'arlésienne c'est un sujet
qui revient systématiquement en revanche
j'ai entendu une autre proposition du
ministre de l'éducation nationale qui
est d'arrêter les devoirs à la maison je
pense que c'est une absurdité sans nom
parce que énorme partie du travail est
effectué à la maison l'idée serait aussi
de faire si si j'ai bien suivi aussi de
faire ce travail lors d'études aussi est
d'accompagner les enfants qui a besoin
oui bon ça c'est des propositions
cosmetics les provisions de marketing
puis après on va nous expliquer qu on ne
renouvelle pas des postes d'enseignants
qui on va manquer de monde pour faire ça
je voulais également à réagir sur
d'autres choses qu'on dit mes
concurrents j'étais d'accord tout à fait
avec deux choses que madame a dit je
pense que il faut favoriser la mixité
sociale est imposé aux mairies de
construire des logements sociaux à côté
des écoles je pense qu'il faut s'ouvrir
à toutes les cultures du monde et pas
seulement la culture anglo saxonne
je pense qu'il faut prohiber au sein de
l'école le consumérisme et je proposerai
d'imposer les logiciels libres à l'école
et enfin une proposition qui est dans
notre programme c'est que les
enseignants en fin de carrière
volontaires servent à former les jeunes
collègues
on va voir sa fiche et les temps de
parole dans un instant vous avez un peu
plus de retard si vous souhaitez encore
vous exprimer sur cette question de
l'éducation
disons que dépenser pour l'éducation
c'est investir dans l'avenir donc il
faut vraiment augmenter le budget de
l'éducation nationale et non pas
saupoudrer
comment dire pour éviter que
vraiment tout pour que les classes ne
soit pas surcharger en déshabiller
pierre pour habiller paul comment dire
dédoubler les classes de cp par exemple
oui mais ok mais à condition qu'on met
le personnel qui va bien et pas le
prendre dans des classes qui les
effectifs normaux les locaux aussi et
tout ce qui va les faire vraiment faut
investir les temps d'investir dans
l'école c'est pas est-ce que ça doit
être selon vous et on va refaire un tour
de table sur l'éducation le dossier
prioritaire des prochains mois
prochaines années l'éducation
l'éducation est prioritaire moi je
dirais que l'éducation nationale est une
richesse j'ai un enfant de novembre
dyslexiques qui a été qui n'a pas été
n'a pas été voir leur taux finissent
pour être soigné uniquement parce que
ces deux enseignants cpe ont pris le
temps de le suivre
et aujourd'hui c'est un enfant qui adore
la lecture qui me pique mes journaux
pour vous dire à quel point c'est
intelligent et c'est une enseignante qui
s'est donné les moyens et je crois qu'il
faut impérativement revaloriser les
enseignants parce que c'est eux c'est
d'eux que viendront la capacité à faire
de nos enfants des êtres responsables
qu'ils puissent s'insérer dans la
société et c'est une priorité aussi
comme je le rappelais parce que le
terrorisme qu'on a pu vivre via aussi de
gens qui sont perdus et notamment du
fait de l'école mais peut-être de
l'absence de règles de
deux éléments qui leur permettent de se
trouver leur place dans la société
si vous souhaitez réagir sur les
questions d'éducation et en paroles mais
en disant que le que seul un service
public national peut offrir cette
égalité des chances
les enfants la république et donc les
les subventions aux privés doivent être
revus supprimait voire supprimées enfin
barcella poux c'est la question que se
pose on ne sait pas peut aller jusqu'à
supprimer les subventions publiques ou
privées voilà je pense aussi à
l'enseignement libre sous toutes ses
formes c'est aussi défendre de son
enseignement qui permettent à l'enfant
de prendre confiance en soi il ya le
public mais il ya aussi l'enseignement
libre dans sa généralité je pense que
c'était des enseignements importants
le but étant de l'épanouissement de
l'enfant pourra faire un citoyen
responsable on va voir les temps de
paroles qui s'affichent dans un instant
juste après ce sera la question de la
carte blanche vous avez laissé la
possibilité à chacun et à chacune de
vous exprimer sur une thématique que
vous considérez comme centrale dans le
cadre de ce scrutin législatif vous
voyez vous êtes tous a à peu près à
trois minutes emmanuel bojan en revance
et jeudi avec geof qui vous êtes un
petit peu moins on va commencer donc
avec vous quel est le sujet que vous
souhaitez porter devant les électeurs de
cette 1ère circonscription
alors moi j'ai deux sujets qui me qui me
tient à coeur c'est à la fois la
sécurité parce qu'on vit une époque
extrêmement grave
il y en a besoin de se défendre face aux
gens qui nous attaque
je pense qu'il faut rétablir les
quarante mille postes de policiers de
douaniers
gendarmes pour soldats qui ont été
supprimés sous les mandats de nicolas
sarkozy et françois hollande il faut
augmenter les budgets liés à la sécurité
à la lutte contre le terrorisme en
matière de sécurité je ferai aussi je
m'intéresserai tout particulièrement à
la lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes
je suis un féministe convaincue et je
pense que c'est la marque d'une société
éclairée de pouvoir défendre le sexe dit
faible et en même temps outre ces
thématiques qui sont graves la sécurité
puisque c'est la sécurité quand même la
première liberté que l'on doit et qu'on
l'on peut octroyer aux français
j'aimerais aussi que l'on redonne espoir
aux français et dans cette optique
j'aimerais donner plus de place à la
culture au sport et au budget de la
recherche parce que je pense qu'il faut
donner à la jeunesse française
l'espoir et la possibilité de s'élever
et donner au français la possibilité de
d'aimer leur pays des mes leur métier et
et de s'émanciper
vous pouvez les uns les autres bien
évidemment réagir avant d'ensuite de
vous exprimer sur les sujets que vous
souhaitez vous mettre mettre en avant
peut-être une parenthèse sur la question
de la sécurité aussi puisque emmanuel
macron prévoit la création imminente
d'une task force à l'elysée ça sert à
quelque chose
alors vous changer un peu de sujet plus
que la carte blanche que j'avais prévu
c'était que j'en parlais tout à l'heure
on va y venir la carte blanche était
juste pour faire plaisir sur la sécurité
parce qu'elle a abordé je vous le vous
prenez au dépourvu donc la sécurité nous
sommes sous l'état d'urgence sous le
sixième renouvellement donc ça a
commencé le 14 novembre 2015 suite aux
attentats du bataclan de la veille qui
s'appliquent sur tout le territoire
français y compris en guyane où je pense
qu'il ya eu aucun djihadistes depuis
adam et eve
il a été renouvelé il a été renouvelé
gelé 18 fois moi ce que je souhaite
c'est que mon pays n'appartiennent à
aucune alliance militaire permanente ne
soit pas aligné systématiquement sur le
gouvernement des états unis d'amérique
qui ne prennent pas participation à des
guerres illégales je sais pas si vous
avez déjà écouté les discours de
propagande de dèche à moi je les fais
pas ce qu'on me disait oui veulent
combattre la chrétienté les croisés et
imposer la charia tu sais c'est pas du
tout ce qu'ils disent
en fait ce qu'ils expliquent ces vous
tuer des femmes et des enfants innocents
chez nous et on va faire dix fois plus
chez vous alors il ça marche très bien
pour recruter des gens c'est à dire que
effectivement je refuse que mon pays
participent à la coalition en syrie je
trouve absolument condamnable le fait
que nous soyons à les détruire de l'état
libyen je considère que nous n'avons pas
à être sur un théâtre d'opérations en
afghanistan ou en irak
et donc pour moi il faut tirer les
conclusions de tout ce que je viens de
dire et sortir de l'organisation du
traité de l'atlantique nord
pour le parti communiste quelle est
votre position sur ces questions de
sécurité elle renouvellement encore de
l'état d'urgence la création d'une task
force pour la sécurité nous dit
l'état doit assurer d'insécurité au
quotidien et agir contre l'insécurité
internationale et le terrorisme pour
cela il suffit pas de décréter l'état
d'urgence il faut encore donner les
moyens aux policiers aux agents
administratifs via fonction publique
aussi qui travaillent dans les
ministères on va aussi de la défense que
de l'intérieur
renforcer la formation aussi heureux
valoriser leurs salaires il faut
intégrer toutes les polices de sécurité
publique dans un grand service public
unifié
donc il faut donner leurs moyens les
moyens d'une vraie prévention avec le
recrutement d'éducateurs de rue parce
que je pense que c'était vraiment
efficaces et qu'ils ont
était pour beaucoup passer à la trappe
ainsi on peut dire le retour d'une
police de proximité avec les moyens
humains et matériels conséquents alors
qu'on assiste y compris dans notre
département à la fermeture de
commissariats et postes de police ce qui
est une aberration est en contradiction
totale avec les discours
sinon il faut également un renforcement
pour la justice le ministère de la
justice la sécurité sociale la
prévention et l'accompagnement social ce
qui évitera certainement de ne pas voir
de vos nous éviterait de voir apparaître
des problèmes dans des quartiers parce
qu'on n'y est pas j'en viens à vous sur
les questions de sécurité et ensuite on
fera le tour de table concernant la
carte blanche sur la question de
sécurité je crois qu'il faut que les
français se prépare à avoir une
vingtaine d'années difficiles je crois
que les actes de terrorisme
d'aujourd'hui sont très semblables le
premier j'ai envie de dire il vient de
en 1995 on l'a peut être oublié mais
métro maison blanche
un jeune de banlieue de de bron s'est
fait exploser dans le métro et au nom du
gia algérien les attentats qu'on vit
depuis deux trois ans c'est à peu près
le même scénario s'est des jeunes de
banlieue perdue
on a expliqué peut-être pourquoi tout à
l'heure on a l'état d'urgence depuis 18
mois
j'ai envie de dire faut arrêter avec
était de chance parce que entretenir un
climat de défiance et de peur auprès des
français c'est dangereux le meilleur
moyen de nous la sécurité pour nous
français c'est de nous prendre en main
c'est à dire d'être capable disait de de
constater dans un quartier dans un
endroit des jeunes qui partent un petit
peu en vrille
c'est d'être capable avec une police de
proximité parce que je crois que le
renseignement est essentielle l'état
d'urgence ne permet pas le renseignement
ou ne facilite pas comme le dit le
conseil d'état qui est quand même la
plus haute institution illustratif de
france qui a expliqué qui nous a
expliqué que l'état d'urgence avait
efficace et trois premiers mois voire
les six premiers et depuis on a mis une
chape de plomb sur la sécurité des
français en leur disant on s'occupe de
tout résultat la pente à nice l'attentât
l'assassinât du père amène à gargenville
l'état d'urgence n'a rien empêché et par
rapport à cette forme de terrorisme qui
on a face à nous des gens qui sont prêts
à se faire exploser
on peut mettre des policiers partout
dans la rue ça ne change rien par contre
on se doit nous limiter néanmoins les
attentats ça peut les lire nasser dans
les formes étaient déjoués oui mais ça
ne change pas grand chose au fond c'est
à dire que l'attentât de nice 86 morts
il y avait sept ans n'étant pas est à
l'urgence dans une ville la plus
surveillée de france ça ne l'a pas
empêché je ne dis pas que l'état doit
pas protéger doit mettre tous les moyens
pour le faire mais je pense que c'est la
sécurité est une affaire de tous
aujourd'hui et que nous nous devons nous
de nous prendre en main et d'être
capable de regarder son voisin comment
ça se passe aujourd'hui est ce que tes
enfants vont bien est-ce qu'ils sont pas
en train de dévier etc etc
ensuite parce que vous devrez brièvement
à la police de proximité parce que cet
impératif d'avoir un lien avec les
habitants
je crois qu'il faut favoriser mutualiser
les services de renseignements je crois
qu'il faut renforcer aussi la
coopération européenne parce que les
fonderies la frontière donc les
restaurer russes n'ont pas de frontières
et on s'arrêtera là si vous souhaitez
réagir sur l'a7 question de la sécurité
notamment
moi je pense que l'état d'urgence et et
malgré tout nécessaire il faut un
dispositif qui soit à la hauteur de la
de la menace et certains n'a pas empêché
des attentats mais comme vous le dis ça
on a aussi permis d'en déjouer
énormément je voudrais une toute
dernière chose en matière d'emploi je
pense qu'il faut redonner envie aux
français d'être audacieux d'innover et
ils redonner du pouvoir d'achat aux
français ça passe par la baisse des
impôts sur le revenu ça passe par
peut-être la suppression des droits de
succession et puis donner la priorité
aux autres entreprises locales et aux
pme
baisser les charges des pme et donner la
priorité aux entreprises qui produisent
sur notre sol j'en reviens à cette carte
blanche
on a changé un petit peu le rythme de
l'émission le sujet quel était le sujet
que vous souhaitez porter mettre en
avant dans ce scrutin je vais répondre
justement c'est moi qui vais vous
prendre au dépourvu je vais encore une
chose à dire sur l'état d'urgence ce cas
les et brièvement parce qu'après on
aurait eu un temps pour la conclusion
autre problème est que disait monsieur
est vrai et montre à propos de
l'attentât de nice qu'il est mal
appliquée c'était à d'urgence on le voit
aussi avec mis debout j'ai rien compte
tenu de bout j'y suis allé j'ai passé
une très bonne soirée place de la
république mais ça me semble aberrant
qu'on permette ce genre de rassemblement
en état d'urgence
la dernière chose que je voulais dire
c'est que le ministère de la défense qui
existait depuis 60 ans a été remplacé
par un ministère des armées
la défense bien dire ce que ça veut dire
voilà je souffre
que mon pays se défendent et n'agresse
personne le ministère des armées quelle
est la prochaine étape pour revenir au
ministère de la guerre alors je vais
parler rapidement de la carte blanche
moi je souhaite la faire sur la
moralisation de la vie publique
par exemple après un projet très concret
que je porterai à l'assemblée si vous
m'élisez députés
c'est la mise en place d'un quorum de
présences à l'assemblée nationale pour
en finir avec le scandale du lait semble
évident je souhaite également proposer
la reconnaissance pleine et entière et
révocatoire du vote blanc de plein
exercice et enfin le référendum
d'initiative populaire
j'en viens à vous j'aime bien ce que je
skie sur le votre votre carte blanche
pardon et puis ensuite on verra les
temps de parole je sais vous avez un
tout petit peu plus d'avancé je côtoie
l'économie je vais pas aborder tous les
sujets on sait que je faisais là une
carte blanche je suis très bien pour
elle un tournant parce que c'est parler
de ça pour le parti communiste donc pour
ce qui est du résultat des politiques
économiques menées par les gouvernements
tant de droite que de 10 de gauche nous
ne pouvons faire que le constat suivant
nous assistons à une fiscalité injuste à
une fraude massive de 100 milliards
d'euros d'allègements et d'exane
d'exonérations fiscales auxquelles
s'ajoutent 80 milliards d'euros de
fraude et d'évasion fiscale autant de
moyens en moins pour nos crèches nos
écoles notre sécurité sociale nos
équipements et justement la sécurité par
exemple le quinquennat de françois
hollande a multiplié les niches fiscales
et sociales pour les entreprises avec le
seyec crédit impôt-recherche 5 milliards
d'euros en 2015 elle cice 19 milliards
d'euros en 2016 pour quel résultat un
chômage massif des salaires bloqués une
fiscalité qui pèse lourd sur les
familles et les petites entreprises et
pour les plus riches des rémunérations
actionne actionnariale en forte hausse
56 milliards d'euros en 2016 des profits
records pour les entreprises du cac 40
74 milliards d'euros je lis parce que
2016 +32 %
ça suffit à ces deux mots des actes
inutiles coûteux ces cadeaux sont à
gagner d'argent public
ils n'ont même pas de compte à rendre
à l'assemblée c'est quand même aberrant
et nous demandons leur suppression
le déficit public n'est pas une fatalité
voix puisqu'il ya l'argent qui part dans
les paradis fiscaux est tous à
l'assemblée nationale je lutterai tout
mais fort en seconde
comme l'ont proposé les députés
communistes pour de nouveaux droits
d'intervention des salariés dans les
entreprises pour réorienter l'argent
vers les salaires vers la formation et
le développement des services publics
donc ans à votre carte blanche et vous
aviez un peu plus d'avancé donc si vous
pouviez très rapidement l aborder le
sujet qui est qui qui vous tient qui
vous tient à coeur et ce sera après le
temps de conclure parce qu'il est encore
un autre plateau juste derrière avec
d'autres candidats sur cette
circonscription le sujet qui me tient à
coeur c'est de rappeler à tous les
citoyens que nous sommes responsables de
nos élus c'est nous qui les y lisons
donc on a une vraie responsabilité il
faut impérativement la réintroduira
confiance on peut regarder de la france
un sou mais jusqu'au front national
toutes ses histoires ses affaires ses
abus c'est moral ou en tout cas ces
problèmes moraux convoi très récemment
dans les anciens dans les eaux parties
doivent cesser pour être bien la
confiance il faut que les citoyens aient
une offre politique en qui ils peuvent
avoir confiance et pour cela je les
invite tous à se soucier non pas du
parti non pas du drapeau non pas des
intérêts d'un groupuscule ou de
différents groupes organisés pour leurs
propres intérêts mais se soucier de la
personne qui va porter leur voix à
l'assemblée et un député indépendant
c'est celui qui pourra interpeller ses
collègues c'est celui qui pourra se
positionner non pas en fonction d'une
posture d'un parti ou des intérêts de
divers mais en fonction de l'intérêt des
français
et dans ce cas faire avancer
concrètement les choses
je rajouterais une dernière petite chose
en hameaux voter pour un coût de la
dépendance c'est faire le choix d'une
vision 900 c'est dénier aux extrêmes ni
aux arrangements des partis je suis
ancré dans ma circonscription depuis 25
ans j'entends tous les jours dans mon
commerce
les français de tous types et je crois
que je serais à même de porter au mieux
leurs paroles on va passer aux
conclusions si on peut voir les temps de
paroles qui s'affichent et je sais qu
emmanuel bojan vous avaient le plus de
retard plus plus d'une minute une minute
trente de retard sur certains vont être
qu'à quatre minutes les autres sont là
presque tout ça à 6 minutes vous aurez
un peu plus de temps donc pour conclure
les autres ce sera une quinzaine de
secondes si vous souhaitez dire dernier
mot face caméra aux différents électeurs
moi je souhaite dire en conclusion
puisque le parti que je représente
debout la france je souhaite que la
france se relève qu elle ce qu'elle
puisse préserver son cadre de vie ces
libertés et donner la chance à tous ses
concitoyens de devenir des personnes
accompli pour ma part les priorités sont
donc l'éducation l'enseignement
redonnait aussi plus de place à la
culture aux sports à la recherche et
dans ce cadre je pense que la france
peut redevenir audacieuse certes nous
sommes dans un climat très grave et qui
plombent avec toutes ces affaires de
terrorisme mais il faut arriver à
retrouver espoir en nos capacités
nous sommes face à un choix de société
ou l'asservissement au travail et à la
précarité avis ou une vie digne fait
d'un travail reconnu avec un salaire
permettant le droit à une vie épanouie
pour tous y compris à la retraite que on
n'a pas eu le temps d'évoquer ne peut
pas faire tous les sujets ont laissé les
spectateurs peuvent aussi se renseigner
sur les différents candidats et pour
l'heure c'est là la csj va en plus
touchés
votre vote pour une députée communiste
sur un marqueur fort en faveur de la
seconde option genre rc merci c'est à
vous pour la conclusion
pareil maximum pourquoi voter pour moi
je reprends votre question de départ
j'invite d'abord tout le monde à se
déplacer au vote et ne pas laisser les
autres choisir pour vous parce que je
suis un citoyen qui partage votre
quotidien depuis 23 ans parce que je
connais vos difficultés parce que je ne
suis pas l'héritier d'un parti parce que
je ne suis pas un donneur de leçon ou un
professionnel de la politique
et parce que je crois qu'il est capital
d'envoyer l'assemblée des hommes des
femmes qui ressemble qui rassemble la
population et pour le représentant de
l'upm je vais essayer en 15 secondes de
présenter des projets que je pourrais
porter à l'assemblée nationale à savoir
créer un fonds de garantie pour les pme
si vous avez regardé la composition du
gouvernement philippe vous aurez vu
qu'il n'y a plus de ministre ou de
secrétaire d'état à l'artisanat et je
souhaite est également séparé
effectivement les banques de dépôt et
les banques d'investissement pour en
finir avec la mutualisation des et
l'exclusion des profits tout à fait
parce qu'on peut pas jouer à pile je
fasse pile pile je gagne face tu perds
et pour en revenir à l'activité normale
que devrait être celle d'une banque à
savoir soutenir l'économie réelle
merci à tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à ce débat cette seconde
partie de débat il reste encore une
partie avec d'autres candidats qui
oscille se présente dans la première
circonscription si on peut voir les
temps de parole pendant ce temps je vous
le disais voilà vous avez un peu plus de
retard emmanuel bojan je rappelle que
nous respectons ce que recommande le csa
qui est la règle de l'équité avec eux ça
se lit ce sur l'ensemble du temps de
parole accordé sur cette antenne pendant
tout au long de tout au long de la
campagne
merci à vous quatre on poursuit dans un
instant avec trois nouveaux candidats
qui vont nous rejoindre jusqu'à près ce
sujet qui fait le point sur les enjeux
de cette 1ère circonscription
l'échiquier politique de la première
circonscription va-t-il basculer c'est
la question qui se pose depuis le départ
annoncé le 23 janvier dernier du député
dvd sortant françois de mazières
l'homme politique en place depuis 2012
sur cette circonscription qui regroupe
une partie de versailles montigny le
bretonneux guyancourt ne se représentera
pas pour se consacrer exclusivement à
son mandat de maire sur la cité
versaillaise ce dernier laisse la place
à une nouvelle génération de politiciens
sur le secteur et la lutte pour sa
succession s'annonce ouverte
quatorze candidats se sont lancés pour
remporter la circonscription bastion
d'une droite traditionnelle ou françois
fillon réalisé 43 % des suffrages au
premier tour de la présidentielle à
versailles et où françois de mazières a
été élu avec 56% des voix au second tour
en 2012
françois-xavier bellamy candidats les
républicains est annoncée comme le
favori de ces élections dans une
circonscription avec 38,6 pour sont des
cadres en milieu urbain et qui votent à
droite depuis 1963
adoubé par le maire de versailles ce
professeur de classe préparatoire à
paris âgée de 31 ans est adjoint chargé
de la jeunesse et de l'enseignement
supérieur dans la cité royale
son principal adversaire devrait être
didier baichère l'homme de la république
en marche à versailles rallié de la
première heure au nouveau président de
la république pourrait surfer sur la
dynamique
emmanuel macron est en train de
convaincre une population aisée avec un
revenu médian mensuel de 2440 euros
autre outsider pour la députation le
fonds national 3e dans la
circonscription 2012 avec 7 94% des voix
le parti de marine le pen a également
réalisé 23 85% des suffrages au deuxième
tour de la présidentielle
siri perez chef d'entreprise de 50 ans
espère donc réaliser un bon score pour
le fn
pour cela il misera sur les 8,2 pour son
2 chômage la circonscription et un taux
de pauvreté de 12 4%
de son côté le parti socialiste espère
faire aussi bien qu'en 2012 ou isabelle
this-saint-jean s'était hissé au 2e tour
face à françois de mazières mais
s'étaient inclinés à 43 3% des voix pour
faire aussi bien le ps a investi
charlotte rossetti ni 31 ans qui vit à
versailles a fait ses études à montigny
le bretonneux
mais le parti socialiste a moins la cote
sur la circonscription qui compte un peu
plus de cent trente deux mille habitants
la france insoumise représenté pendant
la présidentielle par jean luc mélenchon
pourrait cette fois ci terminé devant le
ps comme aux présidentielles à
versailles guyancourt et à montigny le
bretonneux
le jeune thibault marchal sera le
candidat du parti enfin neuf autres
candidats seront également dans la
course la droite conservatrice sera
représenté par françois billot de
lochner nicolas jacquot carmichaël
candidat dvd se présentera aussi pour le
siège de député on retrouvera emmanuel
bojan jean-loup leroux nicolas robin
plis nat geneviève que jose qui olivier
paréja paul de béton et florence humbert
si vous venez nous rejoindre nous
proposons depuis à plus d'une heure
maintenant sur tv fil 78 ans débat avec
les candidats qui se présentent dans la
première circonscription des yvelines
des débats comme celui ci il y en aura
jusqu'au jusqu'à la veille du scrutin
sur tv fil 78 suivant les différentes
circonscriptions que nous couvrons dans
le département des yvelines dernière
partie concernant la première
circonscription avec jean-loup leroux
candidats de loot ouvrière face à vous
florence inverse qui est candidate pour
demain en commun mouvements écologistes
notamment
et puis paul de béton qui est candidat
pour allons enfants dans cette première
convention donc tous les trois bonsoir
et merci d'être venus en plateau vous
avez sans doute suivi les premiers
échanges vous le savez la règle est la
même le temps de parole et est
chronométré vous pouvez échanger les uns
avec les autres le premier tour de table
de la même manière cette question simple
pourquoi les électeurs
cela devrait vous faire confiance pour
ce premier tour de scrutin donc globale
le vote pour lutte ouvrière c'est un
vote de fierté un vote de dignité ii
de fierté d'appartenir à la classe des
travailleurs à la classe de ce qu'ils
produisent tout dans cette société qui
produisent toutes les richesses et
justement si j'appelle à voter lutte
ouvrière si j'appelle à voter pour ma
candidature c'est parce que il y à un
certain nombre de travailleurs qui se
reconnaissent dans nos idées qui se
reconnaissent dans notre programme 1 le
programme qu'on défend qui est justement
la répartition du travail entre tous
sans diminution de salaire
l'interdiction des licenciements les
augmentations de salaires nous ce qu'on
demande c'est quand même qui est pas un
salaire ni une pension en dessous de
1800 euros net par mois c'est quand elle
est essentielle pour vivre et pour tout
ça on demande aussi que de contrôle est
justement de contrôler les comptes des
entreprises contrôlées les comptes des
banques savoir où l'argent est investi
où l'argent va est tous assez sébacées
un programme de lutte
et justement si j'appelle à voter lutte
ouvrière c'est pour défendre ce
programme de lutte parce que c'est pas
l'assemblée nationale qu'on changera les
choses c'est bien au travers des luttes
c'est bien au travers de ce qu'on fera
dans l'est dans les quartiers dans les
grandes dans les entreprises partout il
ya des travailleurs justement pour faire
entendre nos exigences nous exigences de
travailleurs florence inverse et avoue
même question alors demain en commun est
un mouvement qui s'est imposé de
consacrer 50 % des revenus de son qui
l'aura de l'état dans d antan des
projets qui sont tous au coeur de la vie
des citoyens donc des projets de jardins
participatifs d'habitat coopératif des
projets qui permettent de entre
d'entretenir les paysages au plus près
de la vie des citoyens des projets qui
permettent aussi la décroissance c'est à
dire le recyclage les ressources âge et
lorsqu'on appelle durban mining en
le fait de récupérer des matériaux des
en particulier des déchets électroniques
pour les réemployer dans la fabrication
d'objets et tous ces projets qui sont
aux anges au coeur de la vie des
citoyens il doit y en avoir beaucoup
plus c'est ce que nous voulons
encourager en investissant une grande
partie de l'argent public que nous
faisons recevoir comme parti si nous
sommes élus dans dans ses projets la
pole de biron c'est à vous mêmes
questions bonsoir alors voter pour moi
c'est voter pour les enfants et c'est
tout simplement prendre le parti de la
jeunesse
le constat est très simple la semaine
nationale à une moyenne d'âge de 59 ans
aujourd'hui en 2017 alors que la france
est nommé d'âge de 41 ans
et si on prend le parlement réuni la
moyenne d'âge est de 66 ans soit 25 ans
de plus que la population française
on est donc face à une crise de l'art
project représentativité et allô enfance
a été créé il ya trois ans dans cette
démarche là le but est véritablement de
dams est jeune en politique et on a été
consacrée à saintes où il ya trois ans à
l'occasion des élections municipales
dans le simple but d'avoir une
représentation plus fidèles de la
société et d'avoir une alternative jeune
et dynamique
donc c'est dans cette dynamique là avec
les 15% nous avons fait les 15% des voix
que nous avons recueillis à saint cloud
il ya trois ans que nous vous présentons
désormais aux élections législatives 60
candidats de 18 à 25 ans qui se présente
avec un projet de long terme des grands
axes qui sont l'europe l'écologie le
numérique et l'éducation
le but étant toujours d'avoir une
meilleure rampe rotation représentation
de la société voter pour nos enfants
c'est évidemment pour le parti la
jeunesse mais c'est évidemment permettre
à tous et vous offrir l'opportunité
d'avoir enfin une assemblée nationale
qui puisse représenter la société dans
son ensemble puisque vous parler
d'éducation justement c'est l'un des
thèmes que vous portez dans les autres
programmes aussi forcément c'est quelque
chose que l'on retrouve
c'est le sujet sur lequel nous allons
échanger à présent des réformes vont
venir sans doute dans les prochains mois
très rapidement dès la rentrée des
ajustements en tout cas je vous laisser
la parole paul de béton sur ce sujet là
puisqu'il ya plusieurs propositions que
vous portez des stages aussi pour
apprendre par exemple aux enseignants à
prendre ça fait partie des propositions
que allons z'enfants porte exactement
alors une des thématiques phares de
des enfants et le numérique il faut
savoir que le numérique c'est une un
facteur d'innovation un facteur de
croissance un facteur de richesse pour
notre pays je sais bien parce que je
travaillais à prendre sa chance une
entreprise qui travaille dans le secteur
du numérique et c'est quelque chose de
vraiment qu'il va falloir utiliser pour
l'éducation nationale et on considère
qu' énormément d'innovation va pouvoir
apporter pour aider les professeurs à
exercer leur métier
le numérique vous aider à alléger la
charge des professeurs qui sont souvent
sur mené avec des classes trop
nombreuses et également apporter de
l'accès à l'information pour de nombreux
élèves qui sont dans des situations de
géographiquement enclavée une offre le
but s'avèrent véritablement d'apporter
cette ne se numérique et innovation
éducation nationale il ya également un
autre
un autre point pour l'éducation
nationale quand on aimerait mettre en
avant c'est le le l'apprentissage et la
possibilité de faire des stages pour les
étudiants en études supérieures
professionnaliser le cursus
universitaire ça va permettre de faire
rentrer les étudiants dans le monde de
l'entreprise d'avoir un pied dans le
marché du travail c'est extrêmement
important quand on se rend compte
qu'aujourd'hui les jeunes sont ceux qui
souffrent le plus du chômage est de 9 3
% de chômeurs en france mais 21%
parmi les jeunes de 15 à 24 ans donc il
faut vraiment avoir à faire un effort
sur 7 sur cette partie de la population
et l'apprentissage quelque chose que je
connais très bien puisque je suis élève
apprenti va nous permettre de faire
transition entre les études supérieures
et le monde du travail alors sa mère je
vous passe à présent la parole parce que
en regardant votre programme pour demain
en commun vous parlais justement du fait
que la force d'inculquer
systématiquement des connaissances des
compétences on oublie la part de
l'enfant
oui il faut remettre l'enfant au coeur
de
la problématique de l'éducation et de
l'enseignement et ne plus réformer
l'école en fonction des besoins ou des
enseignants ou des parents tous les
quelques à tous les deux ans ou tous les
trois ans en réformant des rythmes
scolaires des samedis travaillés dès
mercredi travailler ou pas ce qui fait
l'effet de ces de ses changements de
rythme scolaire précipite une grande
partie de la population scolaire vers
les écoles privées il échappe à l'école
de la république à laquelle je suis très
attaché et le résultat est que ce sont
des enfants qui souvent sont scolarisés
dans le communautarisme je pense par
exemple aux écoles coraniques dans
lesquelles sont des enfants qui dont les
parents pour diverses raisons ont
renoncé
à la scolarisation dans le public
d'autre part il faut savoir que les
écoles publiques sont déjà très très
rarement inspecter les écoles privées
encore moins et je pense qu'il ya un
réel problème de danse dans
l'endoctrinement qui peut être fait
auprès des enfants qui sont scolarisés
de cette façon là et je pense qu'une
partie de la fuite vers le privé est
effectivement provoqué par les réformes
de rythme scolaire par le fait que les
enfants dont beaucoup d'écoles publiques
maintenant sorte à 15h30 et qu'
énormément de parents ont beaucoup de
problèmes pour trouver des gardes pour
trouver des systèmes qui soit à la fois
pas trop cher épanouissant pour les
enfants à leur permettre de faire leurs
devoirs et que ça change en plus tous
les quelques toutes les quelques années
dont ils tous ceux qui allaient revenir
sur ces rythmes scolaires en tout cas
une sensibilité au sein de windows sbs
loisirs oui j'espère que ça va être
résolue de façon à ce que ce soit pas
les communes pauvres qu'ils renoncent à
des formules de garde et les communes
riches qui proposent des formules de
garde extrêmement bien encadrés pour les
enfants il faut vraiment trouver des
politiques publiques en matière
d'éducation qui égalise
l'accès à la formation l'accès à
l'éducation et surtout l'accès à
l'apprentissage individuel je parle d'un
apprentissage individuel et non pas de
devoirs à la maison parce que les
devoirs à la maison sont un des moyens
de favoriser l'apprentissage individuel
mais pas le seul
et on peut très bien favoriser
l'apprentissage individuel des enfants
sans que ce soit les parents qui doivent
s'en occuper
n'hésitez pas les uns les autres à
réagir si vous le souhaitez poser aussi
de vos questions et échanger jongleront
pour le pour lutte ouvrière quelle est
la vision de l'éducation vous portez
parce que c'est un sujet on l'a vu tout
au long de cette émission dont a parlé
avec les autres candidats qui vise un
chacun a sa vision de l'éducation nous
notre vision de l'éducation c'est que
mais quand même l'éducation et de primes
en terre les ce dès le plus pauvre le
plus jeune âge un c est quand même dès
le plus jeune âge qu'on apprend à vivre
ensemble
on apprend un certain nombre de d'idées
et nous pour nous le problème c'est
surtout qu' il manque de poids film
manque de personnel dans les écoles il
manque d'écoles on le voit bien depuis
des années depuis quand on regarde les
différents gouvernements qui se sont
succédés qui à chaque fois ont fait ont
expliqué qu'ils allaient prendre le
sujet à bras le corps qu'ils allaient
s'en occuper ce qu'on a pu constater
c'est qu'au final bas c'est le contraire
qu'ils ont fait au contraire ils ont
supprimé des emplois ont ils ont
supprimé des écoles ils sont regroupés
des classes
aujourd'hui on voit bien là les moyennes
dans les classes et ce dès le plus jeune
âge on arrive facilement à des classes
où il y a trente enfants
donc cette question là bas c'est quand
même la question du voile à des moyens
qu'on donne à l'éducation
quels sont les moyens qu'on donne à
l'éducation voilà et donc bah leleu
pour pour pour pouvoir avoir une
éducation de qualité il faut avoir les
moyens le personnel en locaux et les
moyens financiers pour permettre à tout
le monde et surtout dans les quartiers
populaires parce que la question allait
vraiment quand même dans les quartiers
populaires avoir accès toute la digue du
biotech avoir accès des musées avoir
accès à de la culture je veux dire
l'éducation c'est ça aussi les si on
donne pas cette chance là en donnant les
voilà en mettant le budget qu'il faut
pour cela
non il n'y a pas de solution vous
souhaitez peut-être réagir j'aimerais
ajouter un point c'est à dire que je
pense effectivement qu'il faut investir
en éducation c'est extrêmement important
mais un défaut en premier et de mieux
gérer leurs ressources qu'on a c'est à
dire que aujourd'hui je conçois vraiment
de l'école républicaine comme un facteur
de réussite à condition qu'ils puissent
permettre l'ascenseur social
je m'explique c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui on a malheureusement une
école qui ne favorise pas c'est la
mixité sociale
je sais très bien j'ai été dans un très
bon lycée hoche à versailles qui est un
lycée de très bon niveau mais
malheureusement où la mixité sociale
n'est pas assez développée et je
considère que la mixité sociale est
quelque chose qui peut apporter
véritablement à nos sociétés on est dans
une société où malheureusement les
classes sociales ont tendance à rester
ensemble au lieu de se mixer alors que
ces deux sets mixer mixte et qu'on
pourra apporter plus de valeur
c'est pour ça qu'avec nos enfants on on
se bat pour qu'il y ait des secteurs
multi collège qui vont permettre cette
mixité sociale et 7 à bord de richesse
tout simplement par cette variété
si on peut voir dans un instant les les
temps de parole juste le temps de
préciser qu'à présent nous allons passer
à la carte blanche que je vous avais
demandé à chacun le sujet que vous
souhaitez mettre en avant dans le cadre
de votre candidature dans cette 1re
circonscription des yvelines ce que vous
entendez porté à l'assemblée nationale
si vous êtes élu si on peut voir les
temps de parole de chacun vous êtes à
peu près tous au delà des trois minutes
on va commencer avec vous florence
imbert vous avez un tout petit peu plus
de retard 3 min 3 secondes ça joue à
quelques secondes seulement
mais quel est votre carte blanche le
sujet que vous souhaitez mettre en avant
dans cette circonscription notamment
alors je pense que notre modèle actuel
de société est basée sur la consommation
et la surconsommation qui a d'énormes
conséquences dans tous les domaines
politique et je m'engagerai en tant que
député pour faire changer cette façon de
gérer la société et en particulier pour
favoriser ne plus favoriser les achats
de pétrole et de matières premières dans
les pays qui mènent des guerres des
guerres qui mettent des millions de gens
sur les voies de l'exil et non seulement
nous avons la responsabilité ici en
france d'accueillir les réfugiés je
pense que ce sujet est très important et
vous ne l'avez pas évoquer avec les
autres candidats donc je me permets de
l'évoquer sûr je sais plus combien de
millions de syriens ont fui la syrie ces
derniers temps il y en a vingt mille
clients atterri en france pour le pays
des droits de l'homme
une des plus riches nations du monde
c'est très peu et nous sommes capables
pouvons très bien on accueillir beaucoup
plus il suffit d'avoir une politique
vraiment volontariste dans l'accueil et
dans l'intégration des personnes
migrantes en particulier des femmes je
précise que les femmes subissent une
double oppression en tant que réfugiés
et en tant que femme venant de
civilisation extrêmement patriarcale et
qu'elles ne sont pas toujours accueilli
avec des dispositifs suffisamment fort
pour les aider dans leurs démarches de
demande d'asile ici en france et d'autre
part il faut absolument que la france
cesse d'accorder la légion d'honneur à
un prince d'arabie saoudite qui opprime
les femmes dans avec un régime un des
plus
misogyne du monde d'accorder deux
d'accorder des marchés d'armement à des
pays qui on le sait très bien
aide des pays en guerre ou ensuite l'onu
essaye de faire des pour des
interventions de protection de la
population civile
il faut absolument que là les
exportations d'armements cessent
immédiatement en particulier vers ces
pays là voilà c'était c'est à la fois un
sujet de changement de société et un
sujet de politique étrangère parce que
je pense que une des raisons pour
lesquelles nous voulons continuer à
exporter en particulier de l'armement
c'est que nous voulons l'échanger contre
des matières premières dont nous avons
besoin
et pourquoi en avons nous besoin parce
que nous mettons tout à la poubelle
donc c'est notre modèle de société de
consommation achetés jeter qui est en
cause
actuellement en particulier dans le
domaine de la des produits nécessaires
pour la digitalisation la digitalisation
est un phénomène qu'on le veuille ou non
qui va continuer il a il a de grandes
conséquences sur les consommations de
matières premières en afrique en
amérique du sud dans des pays aussi en
orient dans l'est dans des pays où il
n'y a pas de garanties sociales pour les
gens qui travaillent à des enfants qui
travaillent
il ya des gens qui skie qui ont qui
risquent leur santé dans l'extraction de
matières premières qui sont nécessaires
à notre consommation
et ça il faut absolument que ça cesse si
vous souhaitez réagir n'hésitez pas à
gembloux à présent vous soutirer avions
peut-être sur ce qui était dit jean
leroux et quel est votre carte blanche
ce soir
blanche ces deux sujets dont vous n'avez
pas traiter les terrasses des sujets
proposés l'emploi quand même quand même
car avec un sujet qui est fondamental
qui est important je lisais dans la
presse locale
on a une entreprise juste à côté à
guyancourt l'acquis en grève depuis dix
jours rémy l'entreprise vortex qui en
charge de transporter les personnes
handicapées et ils sont en grève
pourquoi parce que leur direction leur
patron leur demande de travailler un
troisième week-end dans le mari
travaille déjà deux week-ends dans le
mois et là on leur demande de travailler
un troisième week end hors normes dans
le mois et ça montre quoi ça monte que
bâle
voilà les entreprises les pattes ils
veulent pas embaucher
il préfère dégradé les conditions de vie
et ils préfèrent dégradé conditions de
travail et ça ça des réelles
conséquences sur la vie de tous les
jours
1 et nous quand on a on parle de
l'interdiction des licenciements mais
quand on parle également de la
répartition du travail entre tous et
sans diminution de salaire c'est
primordial 1 la répartition du travail
entre tous on voit bien d'un côté il ya
6 millions de chômeurs de l'autre côté
il ya des travailleurs qui ont plus que
ce qu'il faut pour une points pour que
ce soit humainement faisable on voit
bien dans l'est dans certaines boîtes
etc etc des crises de nerfs ces des
burnout c'est ce et des maladies
professionnelles
1 quand même on va pas au travail pour
mourir on va pas on travaille on
travaille pas on vit pas pour travailler
c'est ça le truc et donc nous l'emploi
c'est quand même quelque chose de
fondamental des richesses il y en a on
voit bien un tous les jours on l'entend
et surtout en début d'année les
résultats des grandes entreprises
c'est en milliards que ça se compte 1 et
on voit par exemple vous prenez les
usines vous prenez l'usiné de flins par
exemple il n'ya plus de 2000
travailleurs intérimaires mais renault
pourrait très bien embaucher ces
personnes 1 cc personnes qui font
travailler 18 mois les renvois six mois
chez eux et les ronds travailler
dix-huit mois et encore quand ils
veulent pas au bout d'un moment s'en
débarrasser parce que sont trop vieilles
parce qu'elles sont usés justement mais
visé par quoi usés par le travail
donc nous franchement sur cette question
là c'est un point important c est
vraiment répartir le travail entre tous
et interdire les licenciements qui est
qui est primordial pas le 2 mai on sait
être carte blanche à vous et ensuite on
fera un dernier tour de table de
conclusion pour chacun
parfait j'aimerais profiter de ma carte
blanche pour parler des institutions n'a
pas pu en parler donc ces occasions et
un constat qui est très simple à faire
c'est que aujourd'hui il ya 6 millions
de jeunes qui ont entre 18 et 25 ans 6
millions de lecteurs qui n'ont
absolument aucun représentant politique
absolument que représentants à
l'assemblée alors que ce sont 6000 une
personne qui peut voter
allons enfants le parti que je
représente veut soumettre un projet de
loi qui s'appelle donc la loi les
enfants qui veut interdire le cumul des
mandats dans le temps et dans la durée
c'est à dire effectivement qu'un député
puisse pas être maire mais également
qu'un député qui est fait un mandat puis
se représenter s'ils le souhaitent mais
ne puisse pas faire plus que deux
mandats
nous voulons lutter contre les hommes
politiques ou femmes politiques qui font
la politique une carrière et une rente
c'est à dire que une personnalité
politique ne devrait pas pouvoir vivre
toute sa vie sur une élection une
personnalité politique devrait pouvoir
être jugée par rapport à ces actes et
ensuite repartir dans la société civile
et qu'elle reparte dans le privé ou
public ça le regarde mais c'est
important que la politique ne soit pas
vu comme errante et c'est seulement à
cette condition que nous allons pouvoir
avoir un véritable renouvellement ce
qu'on le voit les renouvellements qui
s'est relancé tout le temps mais
finalement c'est juste passer de un
maire un député ou d'un député un
sénateur et c'est quelque chose qui nous
considère comme inacceptable et on
aimerait que c'est ce set
cette situation change pour que
l'assemblée nationale puisse enfin une
chambre propre native de l'intégrité de
l'assemblée et non pas une simple nous
semble chambre des personnes qui veulent
garder la politique comme une rente
c'est à dire que si vous êtes élu vous
limiterez vos mandats c'est une règle
que vous allez vous exactement
si je suis élu et j'espère grâce à vous
je si mon mandat se passe très bien je
me représenterai volontiers
pour un autre mandat mais ensuite c'est
fini je retournerai dans mon occupation
que j'ai actuellement donc je suis
employé étudiants je pense que je serai
plus étudiant mais encore employés et
donc maxi nous disant je pense que c'est
largement suffisant et on va passer aux
conclusions à présent que cette émission
plus d'une heure et demie de débats
depuis le début de cette soirée sur tv
fil 78
c'est à vous florence imbert une
trentaine de secondes le dernier mot
vous souhaitez adresser aux électeurs
alors je j'ajoute que je suis
enseignante et que je suis aussi
précaire dire qu'il y à aussi dans
l'enseignement des gens qui dont les
contrats ne sont pas renouvelés donc ils
ne savent jamais qui n'ont pas de
visibilité à plus de six mois sur ce ils
vont être employés ou pas et que nous
sommes de plus en plus nombreux que les
suppressions de postes annoncées vont
multiplier les cas de gens comme comme
moi et je trouve c'est ce n'est pas à la
hauteur d'un pays moderne d'avoir des
professeurs qui ne sont pas qu'ils n'ont
pas de visibilité sur leur carrière et
sur l'or leur revenu sur le moyen terme
ou le long terme
alors je précise que comme vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure une personne on ne
travaille pas pour mourir on travaille
pour vivre jeu je pense qu'il n'y aura
plus désormais de travail pour tout le
monde
il n'est pas nécessaire de continuer à
entretenir la mythologie du plein emploi
il y aura nécessairement un partage des
ressources et des revenus qui doit se
passer de la feuille de salaire qui doit
passer outre la feuille de salaire qui
va se faire autrement
c'est pour ça que nous défendons la
fonte des la refonte des revenus
minimums minima qui existe déjà en
france de façon à créer un seul revenu
et d'aller vers l'inconditionnalité du
revenu minimum alors c'est à vous une
trentaine de secondes et vous serez à
peu près à 6 minutes chacun donc ces
législatives justement c'est une
occasion pour se faire entendre pour
faire entendre nos
nos intérêts en tant que travailleurs et
pour dire que ben justement cette
société là on n'en veut plus n'est pas
normal et qu' il faut se débarrasser du
capitalisme un que c'est lui qui nous
met dans cette situation et justement ce
que le programme qu'on défend
l'interdiction licenciement le
répartition du travail entre tous sans
diminution de salaire l'augmentation des
salaires
un revenu papa de revenus inférieurs à
1800 euros le contrôle des comptes des
entreprises contrôle des comptes des
banques
c'est aussi mettre en avant la
construction d'un grand parti qui
défende les intérêts des travailleurs et
d'un parti qui défende une société qui
soit basée sur les idées du communisme
et ça c'est ça qui sauvera la l'humanité
c'est ça qui sauvera la planète c'est
justement de se débarrasser du
capitalisme et de de tous et cette
bourgeoisie qui vit sur notre dos c'est
à vous pour la conclusion j'aimerais
terminer ce débat en parlant d'une
thématique de long terme que c'est
extrêmement important doit d'avoir une
vision de long terme notamment les
quatre axes de notre programme donne aux
enfants qui sont l'europe l'écologie le
numérique éducation je trouve que c'est
important d'avoir cette vision de long
terme pour se rendre compte que même si
c'est extrêmement important de de gérer
au jour le jour
il faut pas oublier ce cette vision et
c'est dans cette dynamique là que nous
voulons nous investir avec leurs enfants
merci à tous les trois d'avoir participé
à cette dernière table ronde dans le
cadre du premier débat consacré à cette
première circonscription premier tour le
11 juin
vous le savez 18 juin pour le second
tour il faut décider de qui vous allez
envoyer à l'assemblée nationale merci à
vous merci à tous les participants de
cette émission va voir les temps de
parole pendant que nous concluons à
cette émission demain à la même heure à
nicolas quirion vide sera entouré des
candidats présents dans la seconde
circonscription belle soirée à tous et à
toutes
bonsoir non sens
c'est beaucoup merci à vous
[Musique]